Guten Morgen Tim.
Tim ganz ehrlich ne mit dem britischen passen deutschen Pass und Perso wird deine Identitätskrise sicherlich nicht kleiner.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 276.
Facebook Account habe ich vergessen und Twitter-Account für dein Identitätskrise.
Wenn es danach geht da habe ich schon.
Der ein oder andere.
Ja wenn ich mal so zähle wie viele wie viele Login sich so überhaupt habe hatte mal so alles was man so akkumuliert hat was meinst du.
Jetzt kommt hier der login.de one password längenvergleich.
Ja schwanzlängenvergleich.
Ja ich würde dich auf maximal 200 schätzen.
Also deshalb habe ich 1185 Einträge.
Das ist zu viel lieber Tim.
Zu viel für dich.
Ja bei mir sind ja im Prinzip viele berufliche drin und ich komme nicht auf 1000 muss mal aufhören euch habe auch letztens 195 weggeworfen sich gerade.
Jacob habe ich jetzt nicht mitgezählt was klar darf ich noch mal.
Der du kriegst ja auch keinen Papierkorb hast du auch einen hast du auch einen Login für tickets. Events.ccc.de.
Bestimmt Puppen ja habe ich alles was ich alles vorhabe.
Ich habe.
Glaub ich haben lockenvitz so ziemlich jeder IP44 Adresse.
Cypherpunk cypherpunk hast du hast du dieses Jahr dieses Wochenende wieder im Vorverkauf teilgenommen.
An diesem Wochenende achso du meinst also.
Ich weiß dass du nicht zeigen was ich weiß auch genau wieso der steht doch schon bei uns in Kommentaren.
Doch ich habe einmal auf die Kugel geklickt und mir.
This Union spielt willst du mir doch nicht erzählen.
Ach so dass du die zweite Runde Nähe Niederweis gerade mit jungen beschäftigt.
Ich habe aber ich habe das natürlich wieder ne ich habe gedacht Sonntagnachmittag.
Hat ja sonst nichts zu tun 14 Uhr 11. November,
naja ich habe folgendes gemacht das war eigentlich ganz amüsant wir saßen also zwar konnten Meeting im CCC und dann war es Schweigeminute 14 Uhr für Ticketverkauf und ich hatte eine,
eine Position eine sehr gute Position ich wusste ja wie viele Tickets verkauft werden würden in dem Schwall und konnte absehen dass ich mit Position 1400 unter den Glücklichen war,
habe ich folgendes gemacht habe ich die Developer Ansicht von dem von dem Webbrowser geöffnet und habe mir die Cookies alle anzeigen lassen.
Dirt openVAS Login Token rausgeholt.
Hab den Login vorgeführt Ritters.
Und wer ist als erstes geschnallt hat dürfte sich.
Relativ viele Hans geschnallt haben den Cookie übernommen,
Ricks und Rami machen ja den den Ticketverkauf
meldet sich auch sofort weil wir dann so okay Shampoo gute Idee zum Glück hatten sie daran gedacht weil die Gefahr war ja jetzt dass der Cookie gültig ist.
Erlaubt wird indem Verkaufssystem und dann auf einmal 15 15 Leute gleichzeitig auf den gleichen cookie Einkauf machen aber die hatten,
die hunters diesen Fall vorher bedacht und der Cookie wurde in dem Moment wo eine Person den dann eingelöst hatte gegen einen also zum Kauf eines Tickets eingelöst hat.
Invalidiert.
Invaliden und alle anderen sind dann halt rausgeflogen,
aber chapeau dass sie das so klug gemacht haben weil das ist ja leider über Domains und so sitzt nicht trivial.
Das so das wäre ein Fehler gewesen den man leicht hätte machen können beim Programmieren dieses Systems und sie haben den nicht gemacht und gleichzeitig hat sich eben jemand gefreut der den,
der schnell genug war den Cookie Wert zu übernehmen dadurch meine Position in der Schlange zu übernehmen und damit dann Ticket kaufen konnte.
Ja habe ich fand ich fand hat Spaß gemacht fand ich fand ich amüsant.
Wie lange hat es gedauert.
Also ich habe irgendwie für mich war das so reload irgendwie dann war die Stelle.
Du weißt ja auch nicht wann er dran kam ne.
Ich konnte also lange der guck hier nicht benutzt wurde konnte den ja mehrere nutzen,
und ich habe dann irgendwann so bei appositionen 80 das letzte Mal reload gemacht und dann war auf einmal zack wieder am Anfang des am Anfang des Ticketshop sehr also quasi bei der Cookie im invalide wurde,
also cookie sharing auch schön ausgeschlossen aber ich fand es ganz cool dass da jemand schnell genug war die Werte einfach zu übernehmen und die Position einzeln.
Und dass du qualif qualifiziert auch schon mal ausreichend als Hacker um dann irgendwie auch so ein Ticket in Anspruch nehmen zu dumm.
Ich denke auch das dickes hast du dir verdient.
Glückwunsch an wen auch immer.
Also es gibt irgendwie von.
Keine Rückmeldung irgend.
Unter dem Tweet ist eine Antwort von ja also der ich muss halt die zärtlich den Namen sagen aber es hat jemand geschafft und der freut sich und herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Na ja nicht schlecht.
Aber so kann man auch gutes gutes tun in der cue.
Luis aus und uns auf Twitter folgen kann auch Glück bringen.
Mir auf Twitter zu folgen bringt ohnehin Glück.
Hab mir nicht jetzt oder was willst du das damit sagen.
Was ich nicht wollte ich kann ja nur für mich sprechen.
Ich hatte jetzt bisher noch keine besonderen Glücks Erlebnisse bei dir obwohl ich dir ja lange schon Folge des einzige Glücks Erlebnis was du bescherst ist dieser Tweet der alle Jubeljahre aus nicht mehr.
Und wenn es nur das ist ja.
Ja okay kleine kleines Glück kleine Glückes Feedback Feedback Feedback.
Kleine Freuden ja na gut Jura stimmen mit den Füßen abnehmen brauchen Sie nur die followerzahl anzuschauen dann bis Marvin längsten.
Jetzt schon das zweite Mal dass du irgendwie mit diesem Längen Thema kommst hast du da irgendwie Schwierigkeiten oder so ok net.
Hat ein Feedback gegeben zu letzten Sendung was mir in der Sendung gefehlt hat war den elementaren Unterschied zwischen identity Provider und start herauszuarbeiten.
Der identity Provider weiß wo ich überall Accounts habe der Staat weiß hingegen nicht wenn ich bei einer erwachsenen Videothek,
Autoverleih oder dem Bordell meinen Ausweis und oder Führerschein zur Legitimation vorlege und das weiß er hoffentlich auch bei der Verwendung des
epasus nicht richtig ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt sein dass das Set der fundamentale Unterschied ist zum Start.
Das wäre jetzt bei denen von mir angeführten Karten ähnlich,
ehrlich der Fall dass man nicht immer den vollständigen Identitätsnachweis vorliegt aber der Unterschied ist sehr wichtig und wird von Stefan tesing in einem Löcher längeren Kommentar,
länglichen Kommentar aufgegriffen ich ein bisschen gekürzt habe den,
ständig lesen ich habe ihn aber ein bisschen gekürzt um die sendungsformat hier nicht zu sprengen.
Ja linus hat zum Teil recht wenn er sagt,
darf man doch eigentlich ein System haben möchte indem der Fokus auf den Berechtigungen liegt und nicht auf Identität nachweisen,
weil Identitätsnachweise letztlich gegen einen verwendet wird,
das stimmt ist aber nur ein Teil der Betrachtung denn auch für die Funktion des Gesamtsystems ist Identität also die Feststellung dass zwei oder mehr Funktionsträger ein und dieselbe Person sind,
von Bedeutung und zwar immer dann wenn die Wiederholung oder gerechte Verteilung von berechtigungs Zuweisungen interessant sind.
Darf ich an der Stelle schon mal ganz gute Unterscheidung Vodafone auch angesprochen sodass,
man hier einfach genauer differenzieren muss und dazu holt dann Stefan noch ein bisschen weiter aus zunächst allgemein,
im klassischen Verfahren stellt der Staat einen zentralen Identitätsnachweis als Infrastruktur zur Verfügung die er selbst und andere Organisationen für die Zuweisung von Berechtigungen verwenden können,
Information welche Organisation welche Berechtigungen welchen Personen zugewiesen hat wird nicht zentral gespeichert,
idealerweise ist nur die Identität zentral die restlichen Informationen sind dezentral bei den jeweiligen Organisationen gespeichert,
die Information ob Organisation einer bestimmten Person eine bestimmte Berechtigung zugewiesen oder wieder entzogen hat muss Organisation B bei Organisation erfragen.
Das ist genau das was mad auch benannt hat einziger Hinweis ist das ist natürlich nicht gottgegeben so das hätte der Staat ja auch anders machen.
Aber wir haben dann eben auch sadi Dezentralität,
unseres derzeitigen Systems Ministerien müssen irgendwie Informationen bei anderen Abfragen dauert und so weiter aber verhindert halt die zentrale Hortung,
weiter geht's.
Regelungen wie Datenschutz sollen sicherstellen dass eine Organisation idealerweise auch der Staat selbst nur Informationen bezüglich jener anderen Berechtigung erfragen darf an denen sie für die ihr vorliegende Zuweisung von Berechtigung,
ein nachvollziehbar notwendiges Interesse hat.
Wie diese Infrastruktur im Internetzeitalter sinnvoll gestaltet werden soll ist zu diskutieren da hat im wiederum recht insbesondere die über Nationalstaats Grenzen hinausgehen den Aktivitäten der Menschen sind dabei sparen.
Weiter führt er aus dann spezifisch zu den Identität Provider,
hier ist die Information welche Person von welchen Organisationen welche Berechtigungen hat an einer zentralen Stelle gespeichert ok.
Mehreren Mini zentralen zwischen denen man sich entscheiden kann wie lässt sich die Verlagerung von klassisch staatlichen Aufgaben in den privaten Sektor beobachten,
ob das per sie problematisch ist sei mal dahingestellt aber insbesondere bei profitorientierten Unternehmen kann man einen Interessenkonflikt unterstellen.
Identität Provider sammeln identitäts Informationen in einem potenziell unbegrenzten scope,
und entscheiden nach ihren eigenen Regeln wenn Sie Zugriff auf welchen scope gewähren rechtliche Regelungen die in beiden Fällen den Essgruppe Grenzen sollen gibt es aktuell fast nur auf nationalstaatlicher Ebene und haben daher kaum ein effect.
Too long didn't read trächtig.
Yeah.
Provider sind ein Problem Tim hat recht ihr,
irgendwie braucht man die Identität wie man das für die supranationale Lebenswelt des Internetzeitalters organisiert ist spannend und wichtig privat wirtschaftliche Identität Provider sind nicht die Antwort sondern eine Gefahr.
Weiterer Kommentar dazu,
von Simon auch gekürzt ich glaube kaum das wäre mE oder web-id irgendeinen Fuß in den nullachtfünfzehn Web identitäts Markt bekommen indem Google Twitter Facebook und Co unterwegs sind,
da geht es darum Passwörter zu sparen und Mail-Adresse nicht noch mal bestätigen zu müssten also weitestgehend Komfort.
Das war also der das Kern Argument für diese zentralen einfachen Login wäre mir und web-id
Scheinehe auf die hoheitliche Identifizierung abzuziehen quasi Postident im Internet,
die Post bietet das übrigens auch an nennt sich Post-ID da geht es darum zum einen den Aufwand der identifizierungs Infrastruktur abzunehmen also irgendwelche Callcenter zu betreiben wo Menschen videoidentifizierung machen
oder dem Bundesverwaltungsamt Papierformulare zu schicken um an ein Berechtigungszertifikat WER die oder sonstiges zu bekommen,
wann 0-8-15 Aldi Markt kann ich Linus Bedenken total nachvollziehen das ist eine bedenkliche Zentralisierung,
auch weil es da ein quasi Oligopol gibt bei der Identitätsfeststellung sehe ich das Problem weniger,
da gibt es ja schließlich nur eine identitäts Provider und das ist der Staat alle anderen sind nur technische Mittel Männer schwierig schwierig die werden sich natürlich versuchen,
aus dieser Rolle irgendwie herauszubringen aber ist natürlich richtig nur der Staat,
ist eine legitime Instanz zu sagen es gibt jetzt hier einen einen Tim Pritlove.
Svenja auch letztlich staatliche Dokumente herangezogen um diese Identität.
Jetzt hat der Staat aber und das wurde auch schon mehrmals die angesehen erwähnt,
e-id geschaffen das funktioniert eigentlich auch super ist allerdings nur wenig verbreitet e-id also per Smartcard in der im.
Personalausweis die Daten die man daneben gegen Pin oder sonstiges herausgeben kann.
E-id ist aber nicht zu,
oder ist zu unterscheiden von der qualifizierten elektronischen Signatur zwei unterschiedliche Funktionalitäten des Personalausweises ganze kurzer Exkurs von mir e-id ist der äquivalent zu ich habe den Personalausweis gezeigt er ist echt.
Und qualifizierte elektronische Signatur ist ich habe hier eine dokumentierte Willensbekundung,
geäußert und bin damit z.b. Vertrags reif mit einer qualifizierten elektronischen Signatur könntest du theoretisch rechtssichere Geschäfte machen mit einem e-id kannst du erstmal nur sagen wer du bist,
dass der wichtige Unterschied kleiner Exkurs von mir.
Diese neue Schwämme an identitäts Provider könnte allerdings auch mit der,
III D1 Verordnung der EU zusammenhängen die regelt nicht nur die gegenseitige Anerkennung der e-id Systeme der Mitgliedstaaten.
Soll wohl auch eine technische Interoperabilität kommen sondern auch das gleiche für Signatur Funktionen
das was wäre mir und web-id offenbar auch anbieten wollen zumindest steht da was von rechtsgültigen Dokumenten ist dann wohl die
III DAS,
fernsignatur und das scheint genauso schlimm zu sein wie es klingt Crypto Essen Service für rechtsgültige Unterschriften auf Basis der e-id als Authentifizierung zugunsten der e,
bei DAS fernsignatur hat by-the-way die Bundesnetzagentur die Ausstellung von Zertifikaten für den Perso eingestellt das heißt die Signatur Funktion des Personalausweises ist jetzt nutzlos,
das ist mal wieder so richtig schön schlecht.
Denn bei e-id hast du auch Aldi funktioniert weil der Personalausweis die Daten die dann übermittelt quasi signiert ist,
von der ausgebenden stelle das heißt hier hast du eine Signatur quasi orthographische Sicherung die einen echten von einem unechten Ausweis unterscheidet.
Und die auf digitale Weise vermittelt und dafür bürgt dass dies ein echter Personalausweis für,
meine Person ist daraus wiederum eine Signatur zu machen ist eben grundsätzlich unzulässig,
und das System was das letzte Mal gemacht hat war die Mail übrigens habe ich vor einiger Zeit mal ein Vortrag darüber gehalten heißt Bullshit made in Germany findet man auf Media CCC de und auf YouTube kann man auch noch mal verlinken.
Und Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtete mehrfach.
Haargenau dumpies Länge ist lange her ich könnte aber ich schreib das noch eben auch dass das in die Charts noch mal machen weil ich da auch noch mal.
Den Unterschied es gibt es immer einen Unterschied ob ich meinen Ausweis zeige oder ob ich einen Vertrag eingehe und den unterschreibe deswegen haben wir auch diese beiden unterschiedlichen Verfahren im auch in der.
Fotografischen Sicherheit.
Verstehe ich das richtig dass der Perso eigentlich mal so gedacht war dass man da mit unterschreiben kann aber genau das jetzt auch nicht mehr drin.
Sodia,
die der Hinweis hier von Simon der mir auch nicht ganz klar war bis ist hat niemand jemals die die qualifizierte elektronische Signatur,
wenn verwendet soweit ich weiß also die Juristen vielleicht oder so dann gab's ja dann die Signaturkarte.
Ja was heißt mit dem Perso jetzt irgendwie De-Mail abzuschaffen und es meinem zu benutzen ist dann auch wie auch durch sonst noch mal genau.
Ich muss das noch mal genau anschauen.
Er ist auf jeden Fall komplexes Thema wie man auch an den vielen Kommentaren sehen kann wer hat.
Die uns alle sehr gut sind deswegen lesen Sie ja vor.
Genau sehr gut sind die und dann noch einen weiteren nämlich von,
er schreibt zu den aufpoppen wenn identitäts Provider in Deutschland scheint ihr aber den haupttreiber der Entwicklung komplett zu übersehen der Hintergrund ist ganz klar die dsgvo,
anders als es sich gerne im Netz politischen Zirkeln erzählt wird sind Google und Facebook die großen Gewinner der dsgvo und Treiben in Sachen Compliance vor allem die deutsche Werbeindustrie vor sich.
Der wesentliche Punkt die dsgvo verlangt von den datenverarbeitenden stellen nachweisbare Unterrichtungen zu dem Zweck der Datensammlung doch bisher wussten die meisten,
Werbefirmen ja gar nicht wäre ihre Banner sieht konnten sich also wenn überhaupt nur ein anonymes ok abholen das reicht als Nachweis natürlich nicht,
du brauchst schon die identitäts wenn es eine Zuordnung der Nutzerinnen um compliant zu sein das Ergebnis Google und Facebook schaffen das ganz bequem tendieren NutzerInnen,
haben ja eh schon einen login.
Jetzt will natürlich jeder ein Login haben damit die weiterhin getackerte Werbung ausspielen ausgespielt werden kann genau dafür wenn ihr's Dienste wie verimi aus dem Boden gestampft,
die Zukunft hat er noch spannend wahrscheinlich wird es darauf hinauslaufen dass man umsonst nur noch Service ist mit Login bekommt so ein verimi hat er sicher noch nicht die Marktmacht aber die Idee ist sicherlich da noch mehr Dienste,
und vor allem useit auf die eigene Seite zu ziehen und den Druck zu erhöhen.
Auch nicht gut.
Mal so stehen,
ja komplexes Feld ich habe so das Gefühl haben da so eine so eine so eine Wurm Dose geöffnet.
Mit dem Monster eine Weile beschäftigen müssen meine Gedanken sind da auch noch nicht so ganz klar ne also auf jeden Fall und das haben die Kommentare sehr schön gezeigt es ist wichtig in dieser Debatte die Begriffe gut voneinander
zu trennen ich fand vor allem Stefan Hinweis der Notwendigkeit ebensowohl berichtigung
Nachbar nachzuweisen ja was oft gereicht versus nachweisen dass eben auch eine Zuordnung sichergestellt werden muss Wales.
Dann würde ich nur einen Hinweis bringen das ist in den seltensten Fällen notwendig,
diese Zuordnung zu einer Identität ne wenn ich mich entscheide für irgendwelche also bei Twitter mehrere Accounts zu haben das passiert hier auch in den Kommentaren nullachtfünfzehn.
Ist damit mir geht's nur darum die Begriffe an sich zu trennen weil das ja letztlich auch bedeutet da werden verschiedene Dinge getan und manche Dienste dies hochkommen
und dann mehrere Sachen auf einmal wenn halt jetzt so einen net-id kommt und mich bei den Diensten einloggt und meine Identität auch kennt so dann
macht es ja zwei Dinge ist lockt mich ein und weiß wo dieser Vorgang stattgefunden hat wo diese Assoziation wo diese Berechtigung hinzugefügt wurde + meine Identität man könnte das auch trennen etc also.
Müssen selber noch mal genug drüber nachdenken wir gehen das jetzt hier erstmal als Futter und rechne damit dass ihr uns noch mehr Kommentare schreibt die noch länger sind.
Der spannende Teil an Identitäten ist dass es bisher,
versucht wurde über Unfälle spare Hardware zu bauen,
Personalausweis mit irgendwie kunstfertig Hologramm oder wie die Dinger da drin heißt ja nicht Hologramm sondern irgendwie anders,
bunt bunte Druckfarben Fertigungs Merkmale oder eben dann mit der.
Copolyester.
Trick von der Person ist Austritt Folie.
Deswegen stellt sich die Leute so oft neuen.
Lecken zum Einsatz.
Nachher nachher mit nachher mit dass er hat jetzt einen qualityland Trip Folie.
Der weiteren Verlauf,
der Kunstfertigkeit daneben digitale Umfeld spare Smartcards die in diese Dinger eingebaut wurden übrigens die erste die ersten Beispiele davon,
die besondere Verbreitung fanden Telefonkarten im gewissen Sinne und für Identitätsnachweis die subscriber identity Module,
die er alle immer jongliert die,
SIM-Karten bezahlbar subscriber identity Module zielgenau auch den Sinn hatten sicherzustellen dass eine subscriber identity auch nur einmal im Netz verwendet wird.
Um so sicherzustellen dass die Telefonate immer bei den richtigen ankommen und auch immer den richtigen in Rechnung gestellt wer.
Dann würde ich gerne ein bisschen was in im Anschluss an die letzte Sendung und den momentan stattfindenden Kongress Vorverkauf loswerden und so ein bisschen,
von etwas berichten was der CCC in den nächsten Tagen bekannt geben wird der Grund dass es,
im Moment noch nicht online ist ist dass wir noch an der englischen Übersetzung davon arbeiten,
heißt wir haben da jetzt etwas vorbereitet was relativ bald veröffentlicht wird und zwar,
die letzte Sendung anschließend früher war alles besser,
ja als wir uns nämlich alle noch kannten als der Kongress so eine Veranstaltung war mit wenigen hundert oder dann zuletzt in Berlin wenigen tausend besuchenden und wo du im Prinzip,
so maximal drei Hobbs hattest zu jeder anderen Person die darum läuft der alte Mann,
man kannte sich und die Veranstaltung ist massiv gewachsen auf den,
vom 29.3 m vom 28. mit dreieinhalb zum 29.3 mit 6000 dann 12.000 und jetzt Intimbereich 15000.
Und bei dieser die das ist eben eine ganz andere kritische Menge an Menschen die da ist da hast du nicht mehr die Garantie dass du irgendwie zu jeder Person Draht finden kannst da hasse die Leute nicht mehr unter.
Ich Sachen,
unter sozialer Kontrolle das ist genau der Punkt bzw nicht mehr automatisch unter sozialer Kontrolle deswegen haben wir auch schon wenn ich mich recht entsinne vor 6 Jahren,
das RNS Team geschaffen es müsste beim 29.03 zum ersten Mal gewesen sein kann sein dass es da falsch liege,
und das awareness Team.
Hat ja quasi diese Aufgabe für immer im weitesten Sinne für einen guten Vibe zu sorgen auf der Veranstaltung,
dafür zu sorgen dass es ihm die dass Diskriminierungen nicht stattfinden dass Menschen nicht nur,
mit indem Seko Team Security-Team wo ich gleich zu komme eine Ansprechpartnerin finden sondern auch dass sich um sie selber gekümmert wird als unter Umständen Betroffene von,
Diskriminierung Ausgrenzung oder auch einfach nur Überforderung mit der mit der Situation ja sind für das für das grundsätzliche gute,
Klima auf der Veranstaltung ist das RNS Team.
Fühlte sich verantwortlich und sorgt dafür insbesondere natürlich auch unter Berücksichtigung von,
Personengruppen die in so einer großen sozial nicht mehr kontrollierten Situation schnell mal einer Diskriminierung,
eine Herabwürdigung einer Belästigung oder sonstigen Ungemach ausgesetzt sind für deren Belange haben wir das RNS Team seit sechs Jahren sehr erfolgreich im Einsatz,
ja sowieso seit Ewigkeiten das Pferd Chaos emergency response Team das im Prinzip die medizinische Versorgung sicherstellt
ja was auch immer die Menschen an
Verletzungen haben seist du brauchst nur ein Pflaster seiest du hast mal wieder viel zu viel Mate getrunken und zu wenig geschlafen.
Und auch mit einem bestimmten Maße auch mit emotionalen Überforderungen sich auseinandergesetzt hat bis zu einem bestimmen.
Immer in dem Bereich wie die Menschen das sind ja alles Leute mit,
expertise in diesem Bereich das auch teilweise gerade beim Pferd in ihrer beruflichen Tätigkeit jeden Tag sammeln Rettungsdienst machst du nicht lange ohne auch eine sehr klare,
soziale Kompetenz für diese Situation zu entwickeln in der du Menschen,
da hilft da ist es nicht immer nur dass ihr wie das du knietief im Blut stehst ne und die am Leben hält sondern da ist es sehr häufig ist die wichtigste Leistung.
Neben dem dass du dem die Menschen am Leben hältst und in Krankenhaus bringst dafür zu sorgen dass die in dieser Situation nicht mehr,
sich unsicher fühlen oder in Gefahr schweben mehr sondern das.
Nicht nur Pflaster drauf machen oder auch mal pusten.
Stell nicht so an nein genau genau du gehst ja und das ist tatsächlich es wird auch habe ich ja auch ich habe ja eine Ausbildung als Rettungssanitäter gemacht da wird dir das auch beigebracht wie du,
vernünftige Ansprache mit Mitmenschen es hat das Pferd bei uns insbesondere so wie ich das auch mal beobachten konnte auf auf Chaos Events wohl dann auch mal Menschen in Leimen.
Bekanntenkreis oder Umfeld,
darauf angewiesen waren das igelheft geholfen wurde von denen und genauso 3.. Haben wir natürlich auch seit der Firma glaube ich auch schon seit ewig ein Security Team im weitesten Sinne.
Seit drei Jahren.
Früher war Schutzengel genannt.
Seit drei Jahren haben wir da aber die Crew Crew
das ist eine Hamburger ein Hamburger weibliches Bouncer Kollektiv würde ich jetzt mal so im weitesten Sinne sagen also eine Kuh von Frauen.
Die in ihrer Selbstbeschreibung er versank sind stets mit offenen Augen und Ohren für euch da und wir versuchen wir auch für eine gute diskriminierungs Arme Atmosphäre zu sorgen hat unsere Augen und Ohren offen.
Klären die Situation.
Ton dass sie sehr stark mit dem un ist ihm zusammenarbeiten warum also auch hier in einer Konfliktsituation jetzt nicht irgendwie so ich sag mal,
Pöbel Club jetzt kommen die Bouncer und Knüppeln den Aufstand nieder Situation zu haben wo irgendwelche Typen mit ausgeschossenen Nacken und Bomberjacke kommen und nachher die Fragen stellen,
sondern bei uns ist das ist die Herangehensweise da eben eine andere und das beobachte ich glaube ich auch nicht als einziger als
enorm erfolgreich Herangehensweise die da stattfindet das heißt nicht wenn es da hart auf hart kommen würde,
dass wir nicht in der Lage wären auch darauf zu reagieren aber die gesamte,
Tätigkeit dieser Teams ist darauf ausgerichtet dass es niemals hart auf hart kommen soll und das halte ich für diese Herangehensweise halte ich für eine der entscheidenden Faktoren dass diese Veranstaltung so,
friedlich sind und dass die Leute die dort sind,
immer von dieser enormen guten positiven Stimmung berichten wir letzte Sendung auch wieder darauf Bezug genommen,
heißt nicht dass es da überhaupt keine Fehlverhalten gebe und das ist dann nicht auch eine geringe,
Anzahl von echt ernstzunehmenden Konflikten gebe guckst du als würde sie etwas sagen.
Ich wollte nur kurz zu Sacrow Cro noch sagen dass das Beste daran ist dass die wahrscheinlich noch nie einer bemerkt hat dass sie da war.
Die sind genial.
Also es wenn jetzt viele Leute wirklich das aller aller erste Mal überhaupt,
gehört haben dass es so eine Gruppe überhaupt gibt weil die halt keiner sieht und das ist halt auch schon mal Teil des Konzept ja also das sind nicht irgendwelche breit Schuld Regen Rauswerfer
Typologien die Feder.
Kann keine Uniform.
Einfach irgendwie irgendwo sind sie.
Demonstrieren keine Macht oder sonstiges.
Sind einfach da sind vernetzt beobachten die Veranstaltung aus der dritten Reihe und greifen nur an wenn es wirklich erforderlich ist und das eben offene der dezenter ab.
Das ist großartig also diese die Ansprache die diese Getue,
eben pflegt und auch das Auftreten das ist einfach großartig man kennt das ja von anderen Veranstaltungen wo
irgendwelche Stiernacken rumrennen na und da irgendwie alle böse und prüfend anschauen oder sowas
das führt halt auch zu einer entsprechenden Situation und zu einer entsprechenden sag ich mal.
Antwort darauf unter Menschen die vielleicht sei mal Probleme mit,
Aggressionen haben oder die meinen sich in solchen Situationen behaupten zu müssen.
Hörst du wie 1. Mai wenn die Bullen dann erstmal irgendwie mit 5000 wander auflauern um um für Frieden zu sorgen irgendwie kein guter Anfrage Rewe.
Gerda das also das gibt eben unterschiedliche Wege eine Situation zu deeskalieren und die unterscheiden sich auch in ihrer Wirksamkeit und in ihrem eskalationspotential,
so viel des Lobes für diese Teams die nicht alle drei total begeistern.
Und auch diese Trennung ist auch ganz wertvoll obwohl wir quasi hier somit den Schutt ich sage mal lieber Schutzengel oder so dann mit dem Team
schon eine Engel Gruppe gebildet haben von Leuten die,
den Kongress lange kennen das sind Leute die das schon sehr lange machen die sauber mal auf
unser so asozial ist Ökosystem ganz gut kennen
so die kennen bestimmte Pappenheimer die kennen dieses wer kann mit wem nicht so richtig und wo sind so solche Konflikt Räume
trotz alledem gibt es auch Situationen wo man auch dir aushalten muss wo dann einfach diese Profi Crew sehr gutes weil sie gerade eben nicht in irgendwie alles schon involved.
So soviel zum allgemeinen Schutz der Veranstaltung jetzt geht's natürlich eine,
in meiner Erfahrung so die Fälle die ich kenne ist eine über die über viele Jahre geringe einzellige Zahl von harten Fällen,
harte Fälle CD würde ich jetzt einfach mal grob subsumieren als was auch immer da entstanden ist als Konflikt.
Lässt sich nicht.
Spontan ad-hoc durch eine Intervention Ansprache oder sonstiges lösen sondern wir haben es hier mit einem mit einem wie auch immer gearteten schweren Eingriff in.
Die das freiheits und Sicherheitsgefühl einer anderen Person zu tun,
Belästigung Stalking Körperverletzung Übergriffe im im sexuellen Bereich ja oder auch immer harte Diskriminierungen Beschimpfung also all das was einfach ganz klar,
unter vergehen und scheiß Verhalten fällt und unser Problem in den vergangenen Jahren,
ist dass wir dafür keinen geregelten Prozess hatten wir haben den über Jahrzehnte im Prinzip nicht gebraucht weil die Veranstaltung so klein war.
Das wurde die Person die mit den Situationen betraut waren haben das an Ort und Stelle,
die Situation erfassen können haben das klären können was gerade gesagt kann ihre Pappenheimer du hattest noch dazu dieses Netz der sozialen Kontrolle und das ist mit der Größe der Veranstaltungen eben auch verloren gegangen.
Weil wenn ich sagen dass es komplett verloren gegangen ist aber es ist überfordert.
Es ist nicht mehr so engmaschig.
Genau so ist es schön gesagt.
Das hat dazu geführt dass wenn sich jetzt Menschen mit dem mit dem Vorwurf eines Fehlverhaltens an.
Den CCC in anfangs Seitenleiste gewendet haben dann haben die sich an unterschiedliche Personen gewendet.
Teilweise mal an mich teilweise an Schutzengel teilweise an wen auch immer sie vielleicht gerade Kanten oder gesehen haben und das,
wirklich nicht hinzunehmende Ergebnis davon ist das je nachdem man welche Personen sich die gewendet haben sie im Prinzip unterschiedliche.
Antworten Behandlung und Ergebnisse erzielt haben geht natürlich nicht ganz klar schlecht weil das kannst du so nicht machen das ging ging eben beim paar tausend Leuten ging das so weil jeder wusste wohin eine Situation irgendwie.
Den muss in bei 15000 geht das eben nicht mehr und das haben wir aus den vergangenen Jahren,
gelernt dass wir dafür sorgen müssen dass es einen geregelten Prozess gibt der auch von uns vorher kommuniziert wird wo gesagt hat Passau in einer Situation.
In der ein schwerer,
Eingriff in deine Rechte stattgefunden ich halt das jetzt bewusst so so unspezifisch erstmal kommen da gleich drauf noch mal dann gibt es eine Stelle an die kannst Du Dich wenden an erster Position sowieso immer er Wellness Team
Seekuh Pferd je nachdem was da hin was deine Einschränkung ist ne aber da was dahinter du gerade leidest.
Genau was passt zu deiner Situation.
Jetzt stellen wir uns vor es gibt eine Situation in der eben ein schwerer Verstoß gegen die Prinzipien der Veranstaltung vorliegt.
Und dafür brauchen wir eben auch oder haben wir jetzt geschaffen wir arbeiten da seit Januar dran einen geregelten Prozess der dann dieses Verhalten,
untersucht bewertet und mit nach einem geregelten Prozess der für alle gleich und fair ist eine Entscheidung herbeiführt und,
das ist tatsächlich schwieriger als man dachte wir haben seit arbeiten da seit Januar dran mit verschiedenen Expertinnen und Experten aus
den unterschiedlichen zigmal Expertise Bereichen geht von Psychologen und Psychiater rennen über Juristen ich habe mit Richterin gesprochen um
irgendwie diese Situation zu verstehen natürlich sowieso mit dem RNS Team,
insbesondere weil wir haben verschiedene Herausforderung dabei wenn wir jetzt sagen wir wollen einen Verhalten in dieser Veranstaltung sanktionieren die einfache Antwort ist Seekuh geht hin schmeiß die Leute raus ne Bändchen abgeschnitten fertig
also das ist im Prinzip die die Antwort die sich jetzt alle wünschen,
und es ist leider leider leider leider so dass das nicht so einfach geht,
hätte ich persönlich auch gerne gehabt so ne Siku Team wird ausgestattet mit Scheren und Thema erledigt ne Materialkosten was weiß ich 100 € für ordentliches scheren.
Und das geht eben nicht denn die Herausforderung ist wir haben wenn jetzt da so ein so ein Vorwurf erhoben wird
und wir haben vor allem die Erfahrung gemacht dass diese Vorwürfe auch nicht unbedingt auf unseren veranstaltet also Verhalten auf unseren Veranstaltungen betreffen sondern Verhalten davor
wo also jemand sagt pass auf hier ist ein Mensch auf dieser Veranstaltung dieser Mensch hat mir folgendes angetan vor.
Ein Zeitraum von Mama jetzt mehr als 5 Tagen.
Und auch nicht unbedingt auf einer Veranstaltung.
Nicht auf einer Veranstaltung in in einem anderen Land in einen komplett anderen Kontext hat dieser Mensch mir Folgendes angetan ich möchte,
dass dieser Mensch hier nicht mehr ist so.
Der Anspruch der Person jetzt ist die Herausforderung für uns wir haben das jetzt will ich wissen die Russisch was habe ich aus dem Gespräch mit der Richterin,
wir haben keine Zwangsmittel zur Ermittlung der haben also dass der Chaos Computer Club kann jetzt nicht sagen ok wir laden jetzt,
Eugen Eugen vor zwingen die zur Aussage wir treten die Tür ein oder sonstiges ja mit anderen Worten wir haben noch nicht einmal nachts also nach juristischer Theorie ebendiese die Mittel überhaupt eine Wahrheitsfindung zu betreiben,
wir haben außerdem auch keine Legitimation überhaupt eine Schuld zu verorten also so selbst wenn wir jetzt,
diese Zwangsmittel nicht in Anspruch nehmen müssten ein ein Urteil über eine andere Person zu sprechen das können wir nicht mehr können nicht sagen du bist schuldig folgendes vergehen.
Begangen zu haben ja und dann also wir werden jetzt auch nicht die Institution die dazu autorisiert ist dass das zu tun,
und trotzdem wollen wir hier potentiell eine schwere sind Zion verhängen nämlich.
Im schlimmsten Falle oder im im schwersten Vater den Ausschluss von der Veranstaltung und oder sogar zukünftigen Veranstaltungen,
das ist jetzt der die Ausgangssituation,
ja viele Konferenzen sagen so ungefähr ja wären das gelöst indem wir euch einfach rauswerfen das ist aber letztendlich leider auch ein Willkür Regime unterscheidet sich nicht von oder es ist eben kein geregelter Prozess und,
öffne dann wenn du keinen geregelten Prozess hast öffnest du und das ist das entscheidende so Verzerrungen und Willkür,
und Ungerechtigkeit damit die Tür na wenn dein Ansprechpartner.
Irgendwie geneigt ist seiner politischen Haltung in solchen Fällen einen Einfluss zu geben dann hat der unter Umständen,
ein Eiweiß gegen oder für dich und das darf nicht sein das ist glaube ich relativ klar dass das nicht sein darf,
und was haben wir also gemacht.
Erstmal mussten wir einsehen es gibt keine perfekte Lösung bei der in in solchen schweren fährt Vorfällen insbesondere Erzieherinnen sexuellen Bereich gehst da ist ja selbst die rechtsstaatliche Lösung bekanntermaßen nicht optimal es ist
nur in dem Bereich des Gesetzes die beste die wir bis jetzt haben ja es gibt keine,
Lösung die bis jetzt etabliert wurde die besser ist als das es gibt viele Leute die sagen es gebe eine bessere Lösung,
die Frage ist genügt sie den Kriterien für die beste Lösung,
also alles was ich jetzt erzählen werde heißt das ist das Beste was wir.
Überlebenden Zeitraum von inzwischen 10 11 Monaten mit einer möglichen Expertise schaffen konnten.
Und die Frage ist worauf möchtest du optimieren na du könntest sagen das Ziel unserer Lösung ist Abschreckung,
das heißt du machst einen Baez gegen die Beschuldigte Person,
schmeiß erstmal alle raus und das ist ein Prinzip ist es das geringste Übel meine Person zu Unrecht rausgeworfen zu haben als meine Person zu Unrecht nicht rausgeworfen zu haben finde ich einen total klaren Ansatz.
Würde ich persönlich auch fast,
mit also ich wäre hätte wahrscheinlich eher in diese Richtung mich bewegt dann gibt's den anderen Ansatz naja du legst du legst den Schwerpunkt auf Freiheit und.
Zweifel für die Angeklagte Person was so in der effektiv bedeutet du hast ein Baez gegen die beschuldigen de Person
weil die im Zweifelsfall nicht mit einem stichhaltigen Beweis kommt der der genügt um irgendwie Sherlock Holmes mäßig dann einen ein Date einwandfrei Täterschaft festzustellen und eine
eine Sanktion zu verhängen vielleicht gibt's solche Fälle ist auch gut dann sind die wenigstens einfach,
aber im Zweifelsfall musst du auch damit leben können dass du so eine Situation nicht hast also wir legen unseren.
Unseren primären Wert darauf dass die Freiheit und Sicherheit aller teilnehmenden auf der Veranstaltung sichergestellt das ist unser Ziel wir möchten eine friedliche Veranstaltung haben auf der sich alle Menschen sicher fühlen.
Das bedeutet aber die auch in der direkten Folge dass das was die was wir dann verhängen nicht,
eine Verortung von Schuld ist und nicht eine Strafe sondern eine Maßnahme um,
die Freiheit und Sicherheit aller teilnehmenden an der Veranstaltung zu sichern,
und damit ist es dann auch wieder so ein Begriff den ich aus Gespräch mit einer Richterin habe ein Modus Operandi für die Veranstaltung und dieser Modus Operandi stellt sicher dass sich alle frei und sicher fühlen auf der Veranstaltung,
z.b. indem eine Verwarnung ausgesprochen wird sagtet Pass auf hier mit Androhung des Rauswurf oder dass du,
das eine Auflage verhängt wird z.b. ein Kontaktverbot ist beispielsweise etwas was wir auch in der Vergangenheit schon gemacht haben wo wir einer Person gesagt haben so,
wenn diese andere Person in den gleichen Raum kommt wie du dann gehst du da einfach bitteschön sofort raus.
Du gehst dieser Person aus dem Weg ich möchte nicht dass die dich überhaupt sieht.
Und das ist deine Auflage ja ansonsten kannst du den den diese Veranstaltung genießen der Fahrt in diesem Fall tatsächlich funktioniert und Wanne Lösung die jetzt für für beide,
Personen in diesem Konflikt eine erträgliche war ja weil die Situation da war das die andere Person eben gesagt hat die,
diese Person in meiner Nähe halte ich nicht aus löst bei mir Reaktionen aus Hamm eine Lösung gefunden,
Karneval z.b. auf sein ein zeitweiliger oder dauerhafter Ausschluss von der Veranstaltung.
Oder in eben besonders schweren Fällen potenziell auch der Ausschluss von zukünftigen Veranstaltungen,
das sind die Sanktionen die hier auf eine gewisse Weise sein können können am wichtigstens uns aber dass wir ein Support leisten,
denn auch durch den Ausschluss einer Person ist dieses Problem nicht aus der Welt.
Deswegen haben wir das awareness Team seit vielen Jahren deswegen haben wir das Dekoteam in der deeskalieren der Form und wir haben jetzt eine neue Institution geschaffen das ist die Schiedsstelle,
Schiedsstelle ist für schwere Konflikte zuständig die sich,
nicht Vorort akut lösen lassen z.b. auch für diese Konflikte die vielleicht schon vorher klar sind,
also wenn eine Situation besteht hatten wir im letzten Jahr das eine Person weit im Vorlauf der Veranstaltung mit dem Wunsch an uns herangetreten ist eine andere Person von der Teilnahme der Veranstaltung auszuschließen,
ja da dafür ist jetzt bei uns die Schiedsstelle zuständig und wir haben sehr lange daran gebrütet eine Verfahrensordnung zu etablieren das klingt echt.
Bürokratisch und ne klingt nach nach recht Staat und irgendwie Anforderungen.
So erstmal nicht das Schlechteste willst nach Rechtsstaat klingt.
Ja ich höre in diesem insbesondere im Bereich sexualisierter Gewalt ist das aber für viele Personen auch ein sehr negativ behaftete Sword weil sie eben wissen dass es da einen starken weiß gegen die Beschuldigungen Person gibt,
kann man jetzt lange drüber diskutieren warum,
viele Jahrzehnte von Rechtsgelehrten sagen das muss so sein kann man aber auch einfach mal sagen ja das ist aber dann halt auch trotzdem scheiße,
was macht also die Verfahrensordnung der Schiedsstelle die stellt erstmal die rechte fest die eine die die die Personen haben,
im Rahmen eines wird die Schiedsstelle verwalteten oder begleiteten Verfahren können eine Begleitperson haben die haben Anrecht auf eine ansprech Person des gleichen Geschlechts alle,
Beschuldigung und die dazu erhobenen Informationen werden beiden Seiten zugänglich gemacht,
Dinge die unter Umständen vielleicht bei uns in der Vergangenheit auch nicht in vollem Maße stattfinden konnten und die.
Auch in anderen Situationen teilweise nicht stattfinden,
und dann gibt's einen definierten Prozess der Einholung von Informationen und der Aussage wird eine besondere Bedeutung gegeben im Gegensatz zu irgendwie beweisen oder so weil,
Vater zeigt keine Beweise haben sie es die nicht in Zweifel gezogen werden,
Vertraulichkeit ist ein sehr wichtiger. Die Schiedsstelle wird sich nicht öffentlich zu Verfahrens Inhalten äußern das was sie eben im Rahmen ihrer,
Untersuchung des Sachverhaltes an Informationen sammelt bleibt vertraulich in dieser Schiedsstelle.
Wir haben in der Vergangenheit Situation gehabt da sollen das eigentlich immer gemacht dass wir uns zu den Inhalten des Verfahrens nicht äußern wir haben leider in der Vergangenheit auch Situation gehabt wo dann,
Personen sich einseitig geäußert haben mit anderen Worten Behauptungen über.
Vorkommnisse oder Inhalte eines derartigen Verfahrens öffentlich geäußert haben,
die teilweise auch jetzt würde ich sagen nicht unbedingt korrekt waren,
Punkt ist wir können das einzige was sie dass der Club an der Stelle hat ist dieses Spiel nicht mitzuspielen es geht einfach nicht,
Vertraulichkeit muss gewährleistet werden ist ein Schutzrecht für alle die sich an dieser Sache beteiligen oder,
ihr Recht in Anspruch nehmen sich nicht daran zu beteiligen das heißt auch bei Falschbehauptung werden und können wir nichts tun außer nicht mitzuspielen.
Und dann ganz wichtig für jedes für jede Entscheidung die irgendjemand fällt brauchst du einen definierten Prozess zur Berufung ja kann ja sein dass,
die Schiedsstelle eine Fehlentscheidung trifft einem muss man dagegen einen Einwand erheben können und dann braucht man auch dafür ein Prozess du siehst das klingt alles sehr höher sein aber das muss so sein,
um hierfür alle Personen eines eine Fairness herzustellen und,
wir haben dass er arbeitet mit eben beratenden Experten Juristen und JuristInnen,
Psychiaterin Psychologen die sich in diesem Bereich der der Arbeit mit Betroffenen und auch mit Menschen von denen soll ich mal derartiges Verhalten ausgeht,
bitte mit solchen Sachen auseinandergesetzt haben und die eben eine Expertise und Erfahrung im Umgang mit dieser Art,
Situationen haben das war sehr sehr.
Schwieriger Prozess kann ich ganz ehrlich sagen und Feedback zu den Prozess nimmt die Schiedsstelle natürlich auch entgegen bin mir sicher dass es viele Leute gibt die,
an der Verfahrensordnung Verbesserungsvorschläge haben oder vielleicht ist auch nicht gut finden was da passiert,
habe ich persönlich hoffe einfach nur dass die Schiedsstelle sehr wenig zu tun hat weil wir,
einfach hoffentlich genau die Community anziehen und das.
Die Atmosphäre bei uns schaffen das da solches Verhalten einfach nicht auftritt,
das wäre mein persönlicher Wunsch und dann kann ich eine sein ich habe einen ziemlich großen Respekt für diejenigen die sich dieser im aufgabestellen das sind.
Langjährige Mitglieder die das Vertrauen des Vorstands genießen des Chaos Computer Clubs und auch von diesem Vorstand in diese Position berufen wurden.
Und ich glaube dass die Arbeit der die sich darstellen,
echte sehr undankbare ist das ist eine schwere emotionale Belastung und das relativ wenig Aussicht darauf jemals dafür Applaus zu bekommen was du da machst ja das Thema ist politisch total überhitzt,
und man konnte irgendwie so sagen so hier ist eine echt ekelhafte unschöne Aufgabe die dir keinerlei Freude bereiten wird geh mal da hinten hin und mach die pass aber auf mit dem wespenschwarm,
der da ist ja das heißt das beste Ergebnis ist du hast diese ganze Belastung für dich,
der ganze emotionale Belastung für Dich aufgenommen und das Beste was du gewinnen kannst ist das der wespenschwarm dich nicht sticht,
dass das Beste was du kriegen kannst ja das ist das Optimum was die was die Menschen da bekommen denn jede Entscheidung der Schiedsstelle wird relativ klar,
politisch kritisiert werden sei es dass ein Ausschluss stattfindet,
oder sei es dass kein Ausschluss stattfindet und da dieses Thema eben politisch so aufgeladen ist ist ganz klar dass die,
Menschen immer für das was sie da tun kritisiert werden und das ist DAF habe ich den größten Respekt dass sie sich dafür bereit erklärt haben diese echt hoch verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe auf sich zu nehmen.
Und ich hoffe dass der Prozess der da jetzt über,
viele Monate erarbeitet wurde die Ordnung dazu und die Hilfsangebote die wir an unsere Besucherinnen und Besucher richten,
entsprechend gewürdigt werden und am allermeisten hoffe ich dass eben alle Leute sich an die,
Prinzipien halten die eben lauten keine Belästigung anderer Menschen keine Herabwürdigung anderer Menschen.
Respektieren von allen Menschen die da sind was konzentrieren auf Gemeinsamkeiten,
und wer da eben hart aus der Reihe fallen möchte.
Und das so in einem Ausmaß tut das andere Personen in Ihrer Sicherheit sich bedroht fühlen.
Da bleibt dann irgendwann nichts anderes mehr übrig als dieser sich dieser Sache zu nähern,
dann dazu eine Webseite aufgesetzt die wie ich gerade schon einleiten sagte sich gerade in der englischen Übersetzung befindet.
Wird in wenigen Tagen dann denke ich online gehen sollen wir auf Events ccc.de noch mal ankündigen,
und dann gibt es vor allem auch eine zentrale Webseite dass es ebenfalls die Sache die wir gelernt haben in den vergangenen Jahren das,
immer wieder Menschen mit der Behauptung auftreten wir hätten keine Initiativen zum Schutz der Interessen sag mir mal von.
Bedrohten Communitys im im weitesten Sinne ja sei dass die sein das weibliche,
BesucherInnen sein dass ethnische Minderheiten die wo wir uns vorhin dass Sie unseren Kongress bereichern und.
Einer der eine der zentralen Schlussfolgerung daraus war halt auch naja wenn die Menschen gar nicht wissen was wir alles anbieten,
dann ist das unser Problem und deswegen haben wir jetzt eben diese zentrale Stelle geschaffen wo alle Angebote dargestellt sind wo sich die Teams auch vorstellen teilweise persönlich,
und wo eben gesagt wird was unsere Support Angebote auf der Veranstaltung sind ich hoffe das wird gut angenommen und mir persönlich ist es ein großer,
Wunsch und ein großes Anliegen dass alle diese Teams sehr entspannten Kongress haben,
und das ist die Verantwortung aller teilnehmenden an dieser Veranstaltung und an die Verantwortung würde ich gerne abschließend noch mal Aprilia.
Was schon anklingen lassen auf.
Marie hat auch zuletzt gesagt hast du hoffst dass ich halt alle auf dem Kongress ordentlich verhalten klar.
In den letzten Jahren gab es aber vor allem auch Fälle die eben tatsächlich gar nicht,
die also gibt es Aufmerksamkeit bekommen haben die aber teilweise überhaupt nichts mit dem was auf dem Kongress passiert ist zu tun hatten sondern eben im Vorfeld.
Die mediale Aufmerksamkeit hatten ehrlichgesagt nach meiner Kenntnis ausschließlich Fälle die nicht auf dem Kongress stattgefunden haben mitunter auch Fälle wo,
der Ausschluss einer Person gefordert wurde die nicht auf dem Kongress war.
Was natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig ist um das mal vorsichtig zu sagen ja also wenn jetzt jemand an uns herantritt und sagt ich verlange,
das ihrem Harvey Harvey Weinstein von der Veranstaltung ausschließt,
also ist es eher den Schilder Sachverhalt weil wir keine Kenntnis davon haben dass der Mann beabsichtigt unsere Veranstaltung zu besuchen und wenn wir diese Informationen z.b. einholen,
und die Person sagt wer sind sie.
Für eine Veranstaltung.
Was nein woher haben sie meine Telefonnummer wir kaufen jetzt am Telefon wenn das jetzt über tätig die Antwort von Harvey Weinstein wäre.
Dann ist das eben sehr mißlich wenn es dann da mediale.
Aufmerksamkeiten gibt und diese diese Position der Community Polizei.
An uns herangetragen wird unter Konflikte verhandelt werden sollen oder oder sanktioniert werden sollen die tatsächlich weder in den.
Aufgabenbereich noch in den Zuständigkeitsbereich noch in den Kompetenzbereich der Veranstalter eines Kongresses Vallendar.
Siri auch ein bisschen befangen aber es ist eine,
eigene Wahrnehmung immer gewesen dass sich oft im Club über Dinge die schwierig sind.
Sehr viel mehr Gedanken gemacht wird und sehr viel härter darüber internen diskutiert und daran gearbeitet wird als es Außenstehenden.
Zugänglich wird,
das nicht ihr habt ihr Fehler das ist bedingt sich sozusagen man kann natürlich hin so eine Struktur nicht reinschauen aber oft war es eben auch genau das was sie jetzt über diese Schnittstelle auch noch mal gesagt hast nehme ich dieses Prinzip von,
ja wir haben da Kenntnis und Schwierigkeiten.
Wir können das aber und wollen das jetzt aber auch überhaupt nicht öffentlich legen und uns dazu erklären.
Einfach weil wir in dem Moment wo wir es tun würden genau diese Freiheit und diese Sicherheit der beteiligten Personen gefährden würden.
Wo ist aber unser Ziel ist genau diese sicherzustellen oder ist man in einer wirklich sehr unangenehmen Situationen man sich so an.
Dauerfeuer ausgesetzt sieht aber eigentlich relativ wenig dagegen tun kann.
Kannst du diesem Dauerfeuer kann ich z.b. noch sagen dass also immer mal wieder Menschen also diese Forderung auch einfach öffentlich.
Back und verkünden na also schließe Taus Personen ja.
Und zudem Printen grundsätzlichen Prinzipien auch dieser Schiedsstelle gehört dass sie diese Entscheidung nicht ohne,
Note öffentlich machen wir die Entscheidung wird den Leuten mitgeteilt die Entscheidung wird in den dafür,
im relevanten Teams geteilt wo er so gesagt wird also ne Person XY kriegt ihr Ticket erstattet Person XY sollte die hier auftauchen wird.
Entfernt aber der wird jetzt nicht eine Liste geführt,
wo öffentlich gesagt wird Schiedsstelle gibt bekannt XY Ausschluss wegen ABER unter also die Verfahrensordnung sieht das ungefähr so vor wenn.
Eine Situation es unter Abwägung aller Interessen notwendig macht dass die Schiedsstelle überhaupt das Ergebnis,
eines Verfahrens bekanntgibt dann wird sie nur das Ergebnis bekannt geben.
Und ich denke das ist auch für alle einleuchtend und verständlich dass das so sein muss dass wir nicht eine Liste machen folgende Menschen sind nicht willkommen bei unseren Events oder also es gibt da ja auch.
Wie gründe er ist so also wird es aber es gibt ne es gibt Leute die führen listen.
Und die reichen diese dann quasi ein dazu die die reichenliste und sagen folgende Personen bitte einmal.
Und da ist eben auch für um solchen Leuten zu begegnen muss brauchst du eben auch so einen Prozess ne eine Verfahren.
Und kannst du vielleicht auch noch mal mal versuchen in etwa zu quantifizieren wie.
Umfangreich dieses Thema eines Januar weil es ist ja nun auch oft so der Eindruck vermittelt worden.
Werden und wie schon fast nichts anderes mehr zu tun
offenden Kongress als die ganze Zeit darüber nachzudenken wie man jetzt auch wir als nächstes rausschmeißen und das Ganze wäre ja irgendwie ein eine Ort des des des Dauer Chance der fortgesetzten Belästigung aller.
Also ich führe keine ist wieder kein Buchdruck und kann jetzt nicht eine sofortige Zahl sagen und ich muss auch dazu sagen ganz klar ne weil sie ja keinen geordnet Prozess dafür hatten was unser Fehler war,
kann ich da jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwie in der Datenbank geht noch dazu und die Anzahl der Fälle sagen ich würde aber.
Vorsichtig sagen dass mir,
keine Fälle von schweren Vorwürfen auf der Veranstaltung in den letzten Jahren,
bekannt sind zu sich schwer definieren schwer würde ich sagen geht da los wo es,
strafrechtlich relevant wird oder bei der betroffenen Person ein erhebliches,
Leid verursacht hat erheblich meine ich in dem Sinne die Situation lässt sich nicht,
dadurch klären das secu zugreift kurz Prozess raus ja diese Situation haben wir unabhängig davon ja ohnehin ja das also,
Personen muss man kann man dabei auch mal auch gar nicht in die gender neutral zu sprechen das sind in der Regel Männer ja sich scheiße verhalten und sofort war sie in dieser Situation sofort eine Sanktionierung erfolgt.
Oder eine Klärung da kenne ich überhaupt keine Zahl da würde ich aber sagen die es sicherlich höher aber jetzt der schwere Verstoß,
der eben gleich mal eine traumatisierte Person zurücklässt oder.
Durch Gewalt.
Durch Gewalt insbesondere im sexuellen Bereich ist mir tatsächlich nicht bekannt dass das auf unserer auf unserer Veranstaltung stattgefunden hätte.
Jetzt soll ich dazu sagen sicher ich bin mir genauso sicher dass ich eine Person finden wird die,
bei uns auf einer Veranstaltung etwas fürchterliches erfahren hat bin ich ganz sicher ist bei dieser Menge an Menschen klingt so ekelig aber das passiert bei dieser Menge an Menschen wichtig ist dass wir als Club uns da vernünftig zu verhalten.
Wenn wir davon Kenntnis erhalten.
Wenn wir davon keine Seiten was wir desweiteren hatten in der Vergangenheit sind.
Würde ich sagen eine niedrige oder eine vielleicht hohe einstellige Anzahl an Fällen oder mittlere bis hohe Einschläge Anzahl an Fällen wo Vorwürfe im Kontext der Veranstaltung,
erhoben wurden im Kontext der Veranstaltung heißt.
Was heißt ich unmittelbar vor während oder nach aber nicht auf der Veranstaltung selber.
Was was ich Hotelzimmer Restaurant solche Dinge oder,
in der unmittelbar in in einem unmittelbaren in einer Bezugsgruppe die den Kongress besucht,
Beispiel das denke ich,
this auch ein klar welches Beispiel aus dem englischsprachigen Raum da gemeint ist und wenn die das wenn es nicht da ist ist eben auch völlig egal aber dass man da eben Fälle hatte von,
dass wir da eben mit mit Fällen konfrontiert wurden wo es in einer Bezugsgruppe in einer Community die über einen großen Ozean zu uns kommt.
Eben eine Konfliktsituation gab die dann an uns herangetragen wurde mit dem Wunsch dass wir dafür den für den für den Frieden und die Sicherheit der Veranstaltung Sorge tragen was wir in dem Fall ja auch gemacht habe.
Aber trotzdem auch der Eindruck entstanden ist nach außen das hätte alles irgendwie unmittelbar mit dem Kongress zu tun.
Genau der der Eindruck entstand nach außen ist das unmittelbar mit dem Kongress zu tun hatte das ist nicht der Fall und zweitens.
Hatten wir da eine Situation wo wir genau das gemacht haben umgehend der beschuldigten Person Kontakt aufgenommen.
Unseren Wunsch geäußert haben.
Dass diese Person unser Veranstaltung nicht besucht Person hat diesen Wunsch umgehend entsprochen und der Fall war geklärt,
dann gab es einen musst was aber jetzt quasi gerade sage ich mal,
notwendig oder gewünscht dass alle Organisationen viele
Organisation Hackerspaces hast du nicht gesehen kollektive die mussten jetzt alle eine öffentliche Bekanntgabe äußern dass sie diese Person ausschließen,
und so weiter und das hat der Chaos Computer Club nicht getan.
Was daneben in der Öffentlichkeit dazu zu der Wahrnehmung führte.
Wir hätten das nicht getan wir hätten diese Person nicht ausgeschlossen das sind natürlich sehr missliche Situation,
in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung des des Clubs und der Veranstaltung das sind Situationen die,
lass mal ganz kurz nur auf eine persönliche Ebene zu ziehen die auch für mich sehr schwierig sind weil,
natürlich ich weiß die einfachste Option meine meine Situation oder die des Clubs in dem Moment komplett zu lindern wäre einfach.
Gegen dieses Prinzip.
Mit dem Strom zu schwimmen und einfach zu sagen hier wenn du.
Zusagen alles klar wenn die Nacht der.
Langmesser ist dann schließen wir uns an und das ist das ist eben der das ist das was mit der Verantwortungen als Reichweiten starker Veranstalter eben auch kommt.
Dass man diesen persönlichen emotionalen Druck eben auch aushalten muss,
und dass man sich da eben nicht von verständlichen und begründbaren Prinzipien abwenden lässt und dazu gehört bei auch falschen Anschuldigung gegen,
die Veranstalter des Chaos Communication Congress es nicht.
Den Sachverhalt zu korrigieren wenn es eben so ist dass diese Informationen die wir haben nach unserer Auffassung der Vertraulichkeit unterliegen.
Tja und insofern denke hoffe ich wie gesagt dass wir das sehr wenig in Anspruch nehmen müssen.
Ich hoffe dass das da der Bedarf an dieser Schiedsstelle sehr gering ist und ich hoffe natürlich dass die Situation die die Schiedsstelle behandelt und klärt auch.
Nicht in in der einen oder in der anderen Richtung politisiert werden.
Seine große ein großes Problem dessen wie dieses Thema eben nicht rational sondern politisch behandelt wird.
Und da werden wir uns eben leider denke ich mal darauf einrichten müssen dass wir auch.
In der Zukunft eben nur die Option haben wenn solche Dinge öffentlich verhandelt werden was wir nicht für sinnvoll halten darauf zu verweisen nach welcher Verfahrensordnung,
und nach welchen Rechten und Pflichten im weitesten Sinn oder Ansprüchen der beiden Parteien solche Fälle behandelt werden.
Wo die berufungs Möglichkeiten stehen Einspruchsmöglichkeiten und dass wir hinter dem mithilfe unserer externen Expertinnen und Experten und der eben mit der Entscheidung betrauten Mitglieder,
stehen.
Und diese dann eben teilweise stattfinden den Öffentlichen gegenseitigen Beschuldigungen die finde ich leider leider sehr hässlich und.
Ja kann dann eine bleibt da aber eben auch nichts anderes übrig als.
Da nicht mich an derartigen Dingen zu beteiligen und zwar das geht für die eine und die andere Richtung ne also die diese diese.
Und nicht nur dir sondern ganzen Club bleibt nichts anderes übrig also.
Dafür das ist das wofür die wenigsten Menschen Verständnis haben und nicht da und ich kann auch verstehen weil die erste emotionale Reaktion ist sofort zusagen,
houtrouw und mach irgendwie einen auf tue Gutes und rede darüber ja und
weißt du Ritter die Situation gehen mit gutem Beispiel voran das wird also das ist ja auch ein legitimer Anspruch zu sagen ja hier wer wenn nicht der Chaos Computer Club der hier irgendwie diese.
Diese Community zusammenhält der sich rühmt der gelobt wird in den Dokumentationen letzte Woche drüber gesprochen wer wenn ich der kann jetzt hingehen und klar Leute verurteilen ja und,
das ist mein Anspruch den wir auch in Zukunft nicht entsprechen werde.
Niemand niemand niemand würde bei uns davor zurückschrecken,
bei einer klaren Erkenntnislage auch klare Maßnahmen zu ergreifen und das ist auch schon oft getan worden,
nur die Erfahrung gerade letzten Jahre zeigt Gefälle den schwierig schwierig zu beurteilen da haben alle Seiten.
Also es ist es aber an der Darstellung aller Seiten ein gewisser Zweifel angebracht und es hat sich auch oft gezeigt.
Dass die Zurückhaltung dieser Club dann auch geübt hat später in der Betrachtung,
dem der Große shitsstorm schon längst wieder abgeklungen ist das ist dein gezeigt hat so ja es war auch richtig,
hier mal ein bisschen den Ball flach zu halten weil eben bestimmte Dinge sich dann doch eben als etwas detailreicher und komplizierter herausgestellt haben als Sie vielleicht in der Situation postuliert worden
und man vielleicht gerade noch mal kurz davor wegkommen ist,
die Sache noch schlimmer zu machen als sie ohnehin schon ist.
Unterdessen wichtiger. Die Sache schlimmer zu machen ist eben die Große.
Große Sorgen dass deswegen willst du dass solche Sachen von besonderen Menschen.
In Ruhe behandelt werden die sich dann nicht darum kümmern die eben nicht irgendwie als öffentliche Sprecherin oder Sprecher des Chaos Computer Clubs agieren.
Ja kein Ruf zu verlieren haben in dem Sinne.
Wir haben auch einen Ruf zu verlieren haben ganz viel Arbeit genau die nee.
Ja aber nicht in ihrer Rolle die sie im Club wahrnehmen.
Die die ganz klar hier die Situation haben was ist jetzt hier das Richtige,
was ist zu tun gilt und am Ende keine Sorge haben müssen,
dass oder sich nicht darum sorgen sollen sorgen müssen sollen müssen diese wie das irgendwie öffentlich ankommt ja man will ja keine Verurteilung via Twitter sondern man will besondere Menschen mit expertise in dem Bereich
ja also wirklich unter meine ich halt wirklich Expertise so Systemische Beraterin.
Psychologin die mit Menschen arbeitet die die psychologischen Prinzipien und Mechanismen dieser Situationen,
seit Jahren peek tagtäglich ergründet kennt.
Und auch unabhängig von unserer Szene kennt aber eben auch Leute die wiederum auch die Besonderheiten des Hähne kennen und,
auch entsprechend das Umsetzen bzw so ein Beratungsprozess mit einbringen können und ich finde es einen guten Ansatz und in der nicht auch recht.
Überzeugt davon dass das durchaus fruchten K95 besser als dass man sich halt auch so eine relativ plumpe reaktionäre Verhaltensweise eigentlich die letzten Endes nur Bauernopfer
erzeugt und damit irgendwie auch keinen.
Tja also die das Team der Schiedsstelle wird mindestens einen Work-Shop auf dem Kongress machen um da das seine Gedanken dazu vorzustellen und,
kann nur sagen der mir sehr viel Arbeit reingesteckt und sind für Feedback sind ein Feedback auf jeden Fall interessiert können sicherlich auch,
Fragen klären und mein persönlicher Wunsch wäre nur wenn ihr wenn ihr euch für dieses Thema interessiert und diesen diese Veranstaltung besucht dass ihr das auch,
das Ideen.
Auf eine Weise begegnet dir den Respekt für die Aufgabe die sie sich da der sie sich da überhaupt angenommen haben auch vermittelt weil also ganz ehrlich das ist echt keine Aufgabe die man machen will,
nichts was du machen willst.
Sogar die Schwere des Kongresses.
Das ist das ist richtig richtig.
Belastend und den Menschen gebührt wirklich die höchste Anerkennung und der höchste Respekt dafür dass sie wirklich diese wahrscheinlich eine der schwersten Aufgaben überhaupt hier auf sich genommen hat.
Komme zum Tagesgeschäft Dinos was ist denn hier eigentlich los.
Andre Meister André Meister der Quälgeist hat eine.
Eine Informationsfreiheit Anfrage mittels frag den Staat der hat der Plattform von Arne semsrott,
der ja bei der LM p256 auch zu Gast war gestellt das ist ja sowieso das Hauptarbeit von Journalistinnen und Journalisten Anna biselli hat.
Gestern auch irgendwie getwittert das war der nicht gestern davon Patan gezittert wenn nicht frag den Staat war dauernd aber irgendwie bunte bundestag.de war down.
Deine kleine Anfragen die immer noch irgendwelche weil sie wegen aber so ein so ein Standard Geschirrspüler diese ist da und wie soll ich denn jetzt arbeiten diese Infrastruktur nicht da also ich weiß ich genau auf eine Seite des Bundes war oder eine Seite,
die Information des Bundes hier gut aufbereitet und die Anfrage von Andre war
hätte gerne alle Information inklusive Memos vermerken Gesprächsprotokoll in Entwürfen Notizen Eingabe Schriftwechsel Gutachten berichten und zwischen Ständen zur Überprüfung,
von Produkten der informationstechnischen Überwachung Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung und online Besuchern durch,
externe Prüfinstitute wie berichtet in Antwort 4 bis 6 was bedeutet dass er wollte gerne einfach mal die die Ergebnisse von Überprüfung von Staatstrojaner Software haben.
Also was wurde was wenn das geprüft wurde durch externe Expertise stellen dann sag doch mal bitte was dabei rauskam.
Die Anfragen an wen.
Moment das müsste an das Innenministerium gegangen sein ich gucke mal ganz kurz hier ist der Link.
Ich würde vermuten dass du was ans Innenministerium geht.
Oder direkt ans Bundeskriminalamt an das Bundeskriminalamt ja schuldig also er hat die Anfrage an das Bundeskriminalamt gestellt.
Und das Binde Bundeskriminalamt verfügt ja inzwischen über drei einsetzbarer Staatstrojaner und.
Wir erinnern uns.
An die immer wiederholten Argumente dagegen zieht ihr jetzt einfach mal die von mir zuletzt vorgebrachten das war bei der Anhörung im Bundestagsausschuss 2017,
wo ich angebracht habe,
primär Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit mit der Geheimhaltung von Sicherheitslücken die zum Anbringen von Schadsoftware benötigt werden geht eine Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit einher.
Sicherheitslücke die nicht dokumentiert ist kann doch nicht g****** werden und damit steht sie allen offen nicht nur den Behörden.
Nicht nur den Behörden sondern auch ein und sie betrifft auch alle nicht nur Kriminelle sondern auch.
Privatperson.
Natürlich habe ich auch den unverhältnismäßigen Grundrechtseingriff kritisiert den fehlende billigsten die Notwendigkeit war ja niemand in der Lage war dort überzeugende überzeugen für eine Notwendigkeit zu argumentieren,
wir ha ich habe über die fehlende technische Überprüfbarkeit und Nachvollziehbarkeit gesprochen.
Was hier genau sich in andre ist Anfrage wieder zeigt ja dass wir nämlich dass er sagt,
wenn das Ding noch überprüft wurde na dann zeig doch mal die Prüfberichte wenn ihr da euch so toller externer Prüfinstitute bedient hat habt dann sag doch mal welche.
Und jetzt bekommt er eine lange Ablehnung.
Mit der begründen vielen Begründung unter anderem zum anderen werden die Anbieter kommerzieller Hard und Software,
in die Lage versetzt die von der Überwachungssoftware genutzten angriffsvektoren in Klammern Schwachstellen etc zu schließen,
und den Einsatz der Software unter Umständen dauerhaft zu verhindern dieser Satz bedeutet.
Das Bundeskriminalamt gibt zu dass sie erstens Schwachstellen nutzen.
Zweitens diese Schwachstellen unter Umständen den Herstellern den Betroffenen Herstellern von Software und Hardware nicht bekannt sind und gezielt vorenthalten werden.
Damit das BKA die ihre Software Softwareversionen einsetzen kann.
Das ist ein echt hartes Stück meines war immer klar aber jetzt wo sie ihr gesetzt haben jetzt sagen Sie es selbst.
Jetzt sag jetzt geben Sie es zu und das ist sie so häufig ja in der Politik dazu dass er übrigens wenn ihr das macht dann haben wir alle Sicherheitslücken und ihr wisst das und ihr habt dann mit uns auf dem Gewissen wenn der nächste,
der nächste wannacry durch die Unternehmen wütet ihr gefährdet hier die innere Sicherheit wenn ihr Schwachstellen nicht meldet,
und jetzt sagen Sie mir das so einen roten sind wir können ja die kommt dieses Thema hacken ohne sie zu hacken
Sicherheit ist ja sie sehen das immer so schwarz weiß er muss noch ein bisschen Kreativität gelten lassen so also es wird hier Hacker werden nur weil wir schwarz auf der anbringen,
ich weiß vielleicht sind sie da nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand was alles möglich ist
oder sollen wir ok dann zeig doch mal irgendwie was ihr dabei zeigt sag doch mal für Transparenz ja nee nee nee nee dann dann dann wissen wie teuer die Schwachstellen wann die wieder auf dem Schwarzmarkt gekauft haben daher kommen wieder gar nicht mehr rein.
Tja top vielen Dank super das ist genau die aufrichtige vor auf richtige Form der Auseinandersetzung die man sich in dem Bereich wünscht.
Deine Handlungsempfehlung für alle die die ein Unternehmen führen unter unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern soll ja vorkommen ihr habt ja sicherlich zur Interessenvertretung.
Handelskammern und Branchenverbände und so weiter und dann würde ich ja schon mal fragen bei diesem verbinden,
was wie dieses anzusehen wie das alles so geil finden,
hier der Staat die Unternehmen nicht schützt,
das hier quasi,
Wissenden Auges eine Warnung an Unternehmen Deutschland nicht ergeht.
Weil könnte ja mal sein dass man irgendwie einen Kriminellen da an Ohren ziehen kann und je nachdem wie weit man das
schreiben kannst gibt ja da durchaus Branchenverbände die da schon seit längerem dieses Lied singen aber ich wüsste überhaupt nicht warum es hier irgendjemanden ausnehmen sollte Tennis sind nunmal einfach potentiell alle betroffen
egal wie unten digital euer Business ist,
vollkommen egal ob irgendwie im Wesentlichen Tischlerei Verband seit oder sonst irgendwas,
die Buchhaltungssoftware und die Bestellsoftware und Steuer und Kundendatenbank und so weiter habt ihr alle braucht ihr alle so ist alles offen Internetzugang habt ihr auch,
ihr seid einfach nicht geschützt und hier.
Findest aber bemerkenswert wo der Staat auch immer so ganz gerne irgendwie mit dem supergrundrecht der Sicherheit kommt ja.
Aber nicht.
Da ist es dann auf einmal kein supergrundrecht mehr da passt auch irgendwas nicht zusammen,
also das würde ich dann schon mal den Leuten den ihr da Geld bezahlt dass sie für euch Lobbyarbeit machen und die Branche Stärken schon mal stecken ob das nicht mal etwas wäre wo man sich auch mal drunter.
Wahl Chaos in Hessen Dauerbrenner wir erinnern uns.
Bitte der Dauerbrenner Mörder du bist doch schon du hast gesagt du hast gesagt die dürfen nicht mehr ihre geilen Windows-Tools von uns hat 80 benutzen und deswegen bricht jetzt alles aus einer Hand.
Teilweise hätten sie aber vielleicht auch einfach auf Martin hören sollen weil das wahlweb Hessen das hat der Martin ja damals auch schon in den Fingern gehabt als er in in Hessen sich mit den Nutzernamen test test in das VPN ein gewählt hatte ja,
und dann irgendwie mit Walen Nutzername Wahlen Passwort Wahlen, FTP sich auf dem FTP-Server herum trieb ich finde es sehr interessant ein schöner Artikel in der Frankfurter Rundschau,
diese Pannen werden jetzt zur Europawahl verboten ja also so quasi.
Das wird das hat Folgen ich fand das nämlich stark war die die Überschrift des Artikels ist Pannen Wahl in Hessen hat Folgen.
Wahl Chaos in Hessen hat Folgen bei 81373 hessischen Wahlkreise muss das Ergebnis nachträglich verbessert werden auch verbessert ich hätte auch noch eine Verbesserung einzubringen.
Wird noch so einiges einfallen.
Frankfurt zieht Konsequenzen Stadt Frankfurt zieht Konsequenzen und denkst okay jetzt wer fliegt jetzt raus ne wer,
wer muss packen und die Konsequenz lautet bei der Europawahl am 26.Mai sollen keine Pannen mehr auftreten das ist das Ziel okay da bin ich ja froh dass ihr dass sie vorher nicht hatte tja.
Parkverbot.
Oh jetzt ist er überlegen wie die das versuchen zu erreichen.
Die 4000 ehrenamtlichen Wahlhelferin sollen besser geschult werden das schon mal gut fragt man sich warum wo die vorher nicht ordentlich geschult.
Der Divan überfordert.
Genau die waren überfordert.
Mit den Aufgaben warum wohl nur wahrscheinlich weil die Aufgaben einfach auch unangemessen hoch waren.
Dann wenn.
Für die die haben ja dann per Telefon angerufen wenn es nicht funktioniert hat,
habe versucht und das hattest Du ja letzte Woche schon.
Schön beschrieben dass sie da theoretischen 49 Telefon Plätze gehabt hätten von denen sie in der Lage waren zwei zu besetzen.
Weil nur
weil du zwei Türmen ist funktioniert haben genau 50 Rechner die sozusagen da so eine Webseite offen hatten mit dem an Auswahl wird zu greifen konnte aber weil Verb hat halt nicht funktioniert und deswegen konnte man nur bei zweien was machen aber nicht das einzige Problem wie sich herausstellt sondern es war auch einfach die Telefonanlage war schon überforderten die kann gar nicht durch.
Genau die kam nicht durch die Konten und diese Telefonanlage hatte keine Warteschleife das ist.
Rufe geico.
Die Leute haben wir in der angerufen das war natürlich am laufenden Band besetzt ganz klar weshalb dann die Wahlhelferinnen irgendwann.
Entnervt aufgegeben habe zusammengebrochen sind oder was auch immer.
Sitzt auch machen.
Und zur Strafe müssen die Hitze Schulung.
Und aber wird wird also jetzt eine so eine Warteschleife.
Penisfechten.
Bitte warten Sie Ihre Wahl wird gehalten und ein Anreiz zur Teilnahme an den Schul Schulung solls geben eventuell Geld oder Freizeitausgleich.
Unglaublich und sie wollen sie wollen einen das fand ich am allerbesten sie wollen jetzt einen Plan B haben,
falls das wahlweb wieder ausfallen bräuchte man also eine praktikable Software als Ersatz bereit,
wir brauchen einen Plan B das heißt die haben überhaupt diese Wahl stattfinden lassen oder einen Plan B.
Also warte Schleifen an der Telefonnummer die unter die wenn sie überhaupt jemand anruft wahrscheinlich viele Leute anrufen Schulungen,
von Leuten befahl offenbar nicht geschult hattest und ein Plan B falls irgendetwas nicht funktioniert das sind jetzt die Konsequenzen da frage ich mich doch das gab es vorher nicht ich bin wirklich,
Hi schockiert ich bin schockiert und auch diese diese Überlastung des Servers was hattest du letztes Mal erzählt die haben 5000,
mussten da stimmen eingeben und ihr lasst es wo darin sie mit 1, 2000 gemacht oder was.
1000 Jahr.
Ja wenn du einen Last testen mach
dann machst du den doch eine Tüte also dein last Test muss immer ein Vielfaches sein von der Last die du erwartest nicht ein Bruchteil das ist der Unterschied zwischen Bruchteil und vielfachen sehr entscheidend in vielen Fragen der Skalierung.
Naja aber da die aber alle die Software ist nicht direkt von uns haben sollen das ja alles über diese 50 eingefügten war ja die Lassan ich geringe aber die 50 Jahren
John hinbekommen also ich will das nicht zu sehr beurteilen die Bericht Lage ist da auch etwas unklar also vielleicht treffen wir hier die Wahrheit nicht aber es ist offensichtlich dass hier kein korrekter Audit gemacht wurde von dem eigentlichen weg und was mal schief gehen kann
weil hat ja bisher immer geklappt und wer mit diesen komischen Tools benutzt das heißt man hat sich schon irgendwie ausgeholfen mit Lösungen,
Basis von Computern sprich Ergebnisse werden in komisches offline gehackt komische Software telefoniert mit anderer komischer Software und liefert die Daten irgendwie ab,
nur eben unter jeglicher Missachtung der Grundprinzipien von sicherheit
das habt Ihr ja nun ausführlich dargelegt das heißt hier wurde nicht ordentlich verschlüsselt hier wurde nicht ordentlich die Wege abgesichert Authentifizierung war nicht klar
nur damit es überhaupt läuft weil einfach das ganze mit entsprechend wenig inkompetent aufgebaut wurde das überrascht auch nicht dass du an.
Viel Inkompetenz aufgebaut.
Ja weil ja richtig weil mich überrascht das auch nicht weil natürlich ist eine Wahl etwas was nicht jede Woche stattfindet,
jede Woche gewählt werden würde wäre ich mir sicher wäre das Ding auch innerhalb kürzester Zeit irgendwo und,
nur Wahlen finden eben nur alle paar Jahre Starter dieselbe war alle 45 Jahre so ein Wahlleiter in einem Bundesland mit wie viele Wahlen pro Jahr hat der es denn zu tun.
Wirklich mit sehr wenigen da ist dann irgendwann mal Kommunalwahl und dann sind Bundestagswahlen sind Europawahlen das war's dann,
und die Landtagswahl natürlich und oft sind die ja dann teilweise noch auf demselben Termin und dazwischen ist dann Tumbleweed.
Und,
das Personal ändert sich diese Wahlhelfer sind freiwillige die bestenfalls eine geringe Entschädigung bekommt das heißt an der Stelle braucht man einfach generell Prozesse die zuverlässig sind im Sinne von,
man muss eben nicht sich viel komplexe Dinge merken können muss einfach und straight forward gehen oder sollte man einfach auch,
generell auf Technologie setzen die,
Tunis die um wie gut funktioniert das kann auch ein Telefon sein gar keine Frage aber das wird der Authentifizierung irgendwie hinbekommt und sich sicher ist dass da auch die richtige Person anruft
oder man könnte ja auch selber anrufen weil er auch noch meine Idee das ist alles lifebar aber man sollte es eben auch nicht zu kompliziert machen,
ja sonst wird auch Entzug.
Ja ich bin mir auch relativ sicher dass der Teil den sie da jetzt eingesetzt haben mit Sicherheit nicht den Sicherheits Ansprüchen genügt hat die wir da,
für angemessen sehen das ist einfach nur der Teil den sie hat danach verwendet haben und das,
kann nur mit heißen Nadel gestrickt gewesen sein und ich bleibe tatsächlich dabei dass solche Probleme die sind vorhersehbar und es ist gehört zu einem Managementprozess.
SOA der Verantwortlichkeit die hier zugewiesen ist,
dass du diese Telefonanlagen erreichbar hältst und dir darüber Gedanken machst das dein Plan B auch funktioniert du kannst nicht nachdem planar schiefgegangen ist bei so etwas geringfügigen wie einer Wahrheit sagen ab jetzt machen wir auch einen Plan B das geht nicht,
dafür gibt man Leuten nicht diese Verantwortung.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor
wird irgendwie diese Wahlcomputer nicht verboten bekommen und hätten mittlerweile wäre wieder eine in Anführungsstrichen moderne Regierung gehabt die der Meinung war mein hätte jetzt hier auch noch vitalen drittmarkt aufmachen müssen und werden jetzt eine Wahl Infrastruktur am besten noch mit 10 verschiedenen Herstellern mit 30 verschiedenen
Geräten in unterschiedlichen Auslieferung zuständig und Hardware Revision.
Wie geil meint ihr wohl wär das dann wohl so gelaufen mit dem Backbone der sich,
zeichnet ja also wenn da irgendwo einen Problem wär und die Probleme wären überall gewesen ne also.
Wie sagt man amerikanische Verhältnisse,
wollen wir nicht und insofern die auch ganz froh dass wir uns jetzt hier in Anführungsstrichen nur über etwas aufregen wie,
die Ergebnisse konnten nicht richtig abonniert werden und mussten später noch mal korrigiert werden
das ist insofern auch okay weil wir irgendwie immer hin und Prozess haben aber nicht sagen mussten wir können jetzt ja ganzen Wahlen nicht glauben oder so
da ich muss noch mal ein bisschen was zusammen gerechnet werden und Pipapo aber geht halt auch weil ist am Ende nachvollziehbar vom eigentlichen Wahlprozess her,
gut dass wir uns diesen ganzen Computer Scheiß nicht auch noch an der Stelle aufgesetzt haben wo es einfach überhaupt nicht mehr wird.
Ja noch nicht noch nicht.
Noch nicht die Diskussion wird auch wieder kommen ich habe auch gehört dass es irgendwie auf europäischer Ebene jetzt schon wieder so Anwandlungen,
gib deine Initiative zu ergreifen habe ich jetzt gerade keine konkreten Pointer aber das rauschte nur dich an mir vorbei.
Wir brauchen einfach eine vernünftige quelloffene Software für sowas.
Ist abonnieren wollen immer.
Für das tabulieren die genau für das eingeben die eine Signatur Kette hat von jeder einzelnen Wahlleiterin,
zur Landeswahlleiterin zum Bundeswahlleiter wo wir ganz genau nachvollziehen können von,
allen Wahllokalen das dort genau die richtigen Ergebnisse bestätigt von der richtigen Person eingegeben wurden dass die tabulation Software richtig gerechnet hat das können dann Universitäten ihren
Masterarbeit Studierenden zur Prüfung geben und da kann sich dann irgendwelche Interessierten
jungheit Karin und alte Karin die Zähne dran ausbeißen das Ding irgendwie auf den ordentlichen Stand zu stellen und dann haben eine coole Software entbindet aber am Ende nicht davon,
dass das Ding von jemandem betrieben werden muss der in der Lage ist Ansturm auf einen auf einen Server abzuschätzen.
Und vielleicht mal zwei oder drei davon unten Plan B zu haben das ist das Missmanagement was man hier noch hat das bleibt davon tatsächlich leider noch unbenommen.
Und entbindet auch nicht davon das natürlich das ermittelte Ergebnis von den Wahl Prüfern unterschrieben auf Papier irgendwann auch noch mal eingesammelt wird auf einem definierten weg.
Am Ende wenn die ganzen Wahlzettel verbrannt.
Nennen zählt man das natürlich am Schluss auch da noch mal nach.
Selten kommt es in Logbuch Netzpolitik vor.
Dass ich dir mit uns Arbeit der Polizei lobe,
aber ein Fall wo es immer wieder getan habe ist der des Münchner Amoklauf wir erinnern uns durchgeknallter in München hat glaube ich neun Menschen erschossen,
primär,
Menschen die nach seinem Aussehen hat nach seiner Beurteilung vom Aussehen her er migrantisch waren und hatte sich die dafür genutzte Waffe im Darknet gekauft.
Darknet auch bekannt als deep Web also eine Webseite die.
An schwer nachvollziehbare Mord betrieben wird.
Und nur über das Tor Netzwerk erreichbar gewesen ist in diesem Falle und über die dann im Handel betrieben wurde das,
die Ermittlung Ermittlerin und Ermittler haben relativ schnell festgestellt dass,
der Täter diese Waffe bei einem Online-Forum mit den Namen Deutschland im Deep Web bestellt hatte das eben über so ein hidden Service,
bereitgestellt wurde und die haben das bei dem gleichen Händler,
dann eine andere Waffe quasi auch über dieses anonyme Forum bestellen wollen bestellt und haben den bei der Übergabe ganz einfach verhaftet so wirklich eine schöne.
Also schöne Polizeiarbeit zweitens auch schön blöder Waffenhändler ja Glück gehabt dass der so doof war,
als nächstes haben sie sich dann gedacht na ja was ist eigentlich mit diesem Deutschland in deep Web los das Ding hat offenbar mehr als 20.000 angemeldete Nutzer.
Sowas wie sechs Millionen Seitenaufrufe im Monat und wurde betrieben von einem Administrator mit dem Pseudonym Lucky spackt.
Und Lucky spackt hat er größtenteils Einfuehrung Betrieben also größerer Teil des Austausches dort war,
Foren motiviert Kommunikations motiviert und wenn jemand beabsichtigt hat Verkäufe zu tätigen dann wurde,
das von Lucky Spax persönlich freigeschaltet,
und in einen anderen Teil des Forums verschoben wo dann sagt Verkauf in Klammern verifiziert ne hatte so eine Art.
Bradbury protection system of system Wienerwald Bewertungssystem wo er sich dann.
Überzeugt hat dass der die Transaktion stattgefunden hat sowohl Käufer als auch Käuferin das bestätigt haben und dann hat er ja quasi so diese Reputation.
Seiner Händler dort gemanaged und das ist natürlich,
nicht klug das so zu tun weil das bedeutet dass du dich im Prinzip jedes mal wenn du so eine Transaktion dort eher möglichst und sogar in einer Position bist die zu verhindern wir sogar so aus ich das Default ist sogar sie zu verhindern
der macht sich natürlich der Mittäterschaft schuldig oder der Ermöglichung oder der Beihilfe oder was auch immer dann Juristen dafür Paragrafen ziehen,
und deswegen hatte ich die Polizei auch für den guten Lucky Spax interessiert und Lucky Spax hatte irgendwann einmal sich entschieden für seinen Forum da,
Spenden zu sammeln und weil er weiß visitint Anonymität geht hat er die Spenden per Bitcoin eingesammelt.
Und weil er weiß dass er mit dem Bitcoin allenfalls irgendwie in Berlin Burger kaufen kann.
Oder auf seine eigenen Plattform knarren und Bass und und und Drogen hat er gesagt nehme ich doch lieber.
Deutsches Geld hat er sich bei bitcoin.de angemeldet und hat seine Bitcoins dort gegen.
Euro getauscht das ist ein Fehler das ist ein schwerwiegender Fehler denn die Ermittler
haben sich die Bitcoin blockchain angeschaut haben gesehen ahd bitcoins.com von verschiedenen Wallet in dieses eine Wallet von diesem Urlaub gehen Transaktionen aus London offenbar irgendwie in einem Wallet dass wir bitcoin.de zu schreiben.
Und Bekannte bei bitcoin.de muss man sich registrieren also haben sie dort eine bestandsdatenauskunft,
veranlasst und kamen so auf seine Wohnadresse im Süden Deutschlands und seinen Namen daraufhin haben sie eine,
TKÜ gemacht das heißt sie haben.
Seine Internetverbindung überwachen lassen kriegst du in so einem Fall natürlich relativ schnell beantragt und genehmigt.
Und was haben sie da nativa sehen sie als erstes klar die Person,
kommuniziert verschlüsselt und insbesondere merken sie natürlich ja die die Person nutzt das Tornetz was sie auch benötigt um sich in ihre Server einzuloggen,
wenn Sie das richtig gemacht hat da geht der Atheist der Artikel oder die Berichterstattung nicht ganz klar kann auch sein dass der klug genug war direkt auf seinen Server zuzugreifen und so auch wirklich die IP-Adresse zu verraten das weiß ich nicht aber entscheidend ist,
die Ermittler wollten jetzt eine Situation haben wo sie ihn wie bei Silkroad eingeloggt als Administrator.
Am Laptop erwischen.
Denn das ist ja dann der ultimative Beweis dass du den Zugriff hast das war bei Ross Ulbricht so ich weiß nicht was Ulbricht Ross Ulbricht der,
als Dread pirate Roberts vor ein paar Jahren inzwischen verhaftet wurde den haben sie quasi vom vom eingeloggten Screen Weg gezerrt ja und das.
Flagranti wie man so.
Inflagranti und jetzt haben sie eine echt nicht blöde Aktion gepullt wir haben dem über dieses Forum,
eine Direktnachricht geschrieben haben gesagt hierarchy Ich will dich ja nicht beunruhigen aber ich habe eine ernsthafte Sicherheitslücke gefunden er solle sich in einen Chat einloggen dort würde Erde er dann mehr Details erfahren
und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage was machst du wenn du eine solche Nachricht bekommst.
Wir haben sie diese Nachrichten zugestellt.
Du kannst in define phpBB PHP Bullet in Wort und da kannst du auch Personal messages,
von einer innerhalb des Forums von einer von einem Account zum anderen.
Noch dazu haben sie offenbar einem einen SQL-Injection Angriff versucht,
von dem sie wussten dass der nicht funktionieren würde aber von dem sie wussten dass der traces in seinem Loch hinterlässt,
und das etwas ärgerliche an so einem hidden Service ist.
Du hast natürlich kannst du noch schreiben schön und gut hast du jetzt was dass ich deine Patch oder dein engine.exe und der schreibt jeden Zugriff weg und da steht jedesmal IP-Adresse 127001 nämlich local house,
also,
bei der Setup ja so ist du hast den du hast ein Webserver der hört auf nur auf lokale Verbindungen bei dir selber von dem Rechner der mit sich selber redet und dann hast du Tor,
an zweiter Stelle wo du sagst okay bitte bitte einen hidden Service an und alles was da hinkommt,
unter sowieso onion ja das leitest du bitte weiter an,
127.0 0.1 Doppelpunkt was dass ich 80 80 also lokale an einen an unseren lokalen Webserver das heißt der Webserver die ganze Zeit den Eindruck dass er nicht mit dem Internet redet sondern nur mit dem gleichen Haus,
entsprechend steht wenn du Logfiles schreibst überall ich selber habe aufgerufen folgendes,
was völlig in Ordnung ist nur echt doof ist wenn du auf einmal mit einer forensischen Erwägung an deine Logfiles gehst weil du dann nämlich die Problem hast dass du dein eigenes Handeln nicht mehr rausfiltern kannst.
Gegenüber dem Handeln anderer oder dem potentiell bösartigen Verhalten sieht alles gleich aus in den Logfiles,
das ist bisschen erschwerend ist jetzt aber nicht das ist jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt auch echt nicht mehr Luckys Problem gewesen denn in dem Moment wo diese Nachricht kam haben die,
Ermittler schon mit dem Rammbock bei ihm vor der Tür gestanden und konnten quasi live über ihre TKÜ sehen alles klar jetzt wird er sich gerade eine hat jetzt gerade die Verbindung hergestellt,
und dann ging die Tür auf Fernsehen vom Computer weg gezerrt und.
Hatten den Beweis.
Den Beweis irgendwie hat dann.
Glaube ich noch irgend Polizist vom Server das Stromkabel rausgezogen das war dann so die weniger kluge Handlung die dieser Polizist da verübt hat,
weil dadurch der Serverauswahl und vermutlich so lese ich den Bericht die Festplatten voll verschlüsselt waren das heißt der.
Der Teil der Arbeit ist jetzt leider erschwert die Frage die sich jetzt aber stellt ist dürfte die Polizei das überhaupt,
aber wenn die einen Angriff ein SQL-Injection Angriff versucht haben bei denen sie davon ausgehen dass sie oder von denen sie wussten dass der nicht funktioniert was ja glaubhaft ist die können ja,
relativ einfach die Webapplikation Fingerprint and und sagen okay das ist eine Version soundso und ich versuche jetzt mal ein Angriff der bekanntermaßen auf Version,
drei Versionsnummer davor funktioniert hat oder so.
Was geht ja nur darum in sozialen damit zu beschäftigen aber nicht wirklich jetzt darüber das System zu übernehmen.
Es ging darum dass der an den Computer geht und im Zweifelsfall vielleicht gar nicht in den Chat aber also die die naheliegende,
Reaktion und das ist ist tatsächlich ein psychologischer Trick hier wenn mir jemand schreibt ey dein sowieso hat eine Sicherheitslücke ja dann bin ich auch sofort auf dem Server eingeloggt und gucke.
Also pass auf der Falle.
Diesmal wenn euch einer sagt ich hab die Sicherheitslücke nicht machen.
Genau lass lass lass einfach die Frage ob die Polizei jetzt hier Hacker Tools einsetzen dürfte ist aber natürlich auch eine interessante weil.
Wir dürfen das ja nicht der Hacker Paragraph ist ja nicht so
nicht so nachsichtig ja also wer diese Tools in Umlauf bringen oder verwendet oder so oder jetzt sah ein anderes an täuscht hatte ich eine Grauzone ich bin mal gespannt wie das jetzt doch vor Gericht verhandelt wird
ich glaube nicht dass das zur Berufung reicht weil man natürlich auch argumentieren könnte.
Naja wenn ich weiß dass der Angriff dass der Angriff nicht funktioniert dann ist es immer auch keine Angriff wenn ich nun mal Bobby DROP TABLE heiße er ist das ja keine Angriff ist ja mein Name.
Bin gespannt inwiefern das noch weiter diskutiert wird und bin mich persönlich faszinieren solche.
Berichte ja weil ich ja selber auch ab und zu mal in der im forensischen Bereich tätig bin.
Und selber natürlich auch Server verantworte und mir da vielleicht auch über sicherheit oder Anonymität bei Gedanken mache und dann finde ich es immer sehr spannend über welche,
kleinen oder großen Fehler und fallen die Menschen dann am Ende doch geschnappt werden.
OpSec ist echt schwer.
Aber irgendwie gut dein dein illegaler deepweb Markt Geld über bitcoin.de einzutauschen ist auch echt,
nicht der Klügste super aber was anderes z.b. um den guten auch mal zu zu loben der hatte z.b. darauf geachtet dass seine Webseite immer,
in unterschiedlichen unterschiedlich zufällig großen Textblock mit schick bei jedem Aufruf damit die Paketgrößen die gleich sind.
Umso diese Timing und compilation Angriffe zu verhindern die du jetzt gegen ID quasi,
es unter Umständen ermöglicht hätten seinen hidden Service zu finden weiß nicht genau ob der Wiese denn jetzt gefunden haben oder ob sie nicht gefunden haben,
das ging aus dem Artikel nicht hervor an sich die haben aber sie jetzt auch nicht so somit auseinandergesetzt glaube ich auch unerheblich weil der das entscheidende Beweismittel gegen ihn bei ihm dass er eingeloggt ist und nicht dass Ihr den Server gefunden haben.
Ja also immer gut testen wir Großes vorhatte.
Ja vor allem nicht drüber reden operacional Security ist schwerer Security habe ich übrigens eine kleine Einreichung zum Kongress gemacht.
Uns angenommen.
Ich habe die E-Mail nicht bekommen,
habe mich beschwert aber das war weil ich weil ausgehende E-Mails an mich eh gesperrt waren weil ich ja in einem anderen Track als Security auch selber Einreichungen angenommen habe und das sieht so aus als wenn meine Einreichung angenommen worden.
Mit Thorsten zusammen eingereicht wie letztes Jahr Thorsten Hammer Torsten Martin und ich haben ja über PC war gesprochen und dieses Jahr wollen wir über Operation Security sprechen.
Oder Kongress Ausblick und Vortrags Empfehlung Mama andermal auch gut getestet ist das neue Funkzellenabfrage transparent System.
Burmeier geschätzter Kollege von der Nationen und auch hier immer mal wieder zu Gast gewesen losgetreten hat,
das ist letzten Tagen wohl erfolgreich getestet worden und wird jetzt der.
Ja du tauchen tagsüber im Congress.
Möchte das mal bis angeschaut und ich glaube das ist also ist natürlich sehr gut es ist sehr wichtig dass man hier für dass man hier so ein Transparenz System hat was den Menschen verdeutlicht,
das ist ja die.
Der politische Anspruch an Sonnensystem das ist immer die Menschen die Menschen verdeutlicht ob und wie oft Sie dieser Maßnahme ausgesetzt sind,
und aus der Berichterstattung von andré Meister primär aber auf seinen anderen Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei netzpolitik.org wissen wir ja sehr oft,
im Schnitt wenn man von der Gleichverteilung der Wahrscheinlichkeit ausgeht alle Berliner mehrmals im Jahr.
Und jetzt gibt es diese gab es eben diese Forderung das muss den betroffenen Personen eröffnet werden.
Und dann wurde natürlich gesagt ja neee dann dann waren wir ja die Terroristen und so weiter und so fort und.
Dann wurde lange diskutiert und das was wir jetzt sehen ist eine Lösung die es unter optin.
Den Menschen ermöglicht dass sie eine Benachrichtigung erhalten wenn sie in Berlin zum Ziel einer Funktion Abfrage wurden. Fernabfrage heißt.
Für einen Zeitraum oder Zeitpunkt,
Wer wird von den Betreibern der Funkzelle abgefragt welche subscriber also welche Telefone welche SIM-Karten sich zu diesem Zeitpunkt oder Zeitraum,
in dieser Funkzelle ein gewählt hatten,
natürlich wird das nicht nur von einer Funkzelle gemacht sondern im Zweifel sowieso erstmal von drei an ihrem Standort und dann wahrscheinlich nicht nur
dann natürlich ein bisschen um sicherzugehen ein bisschen weiter draußen herum nicht dass das Telefon zufällig in einer anderen Funkzelle ein gewählt war,
so wenn ich jetzt als Bürger interessiert bin das zu erfahren wenn das mit mir gemacht wurde.
Dann kann ich mich dafür bei diesem System anmelden das ist das FTS Funkzellenabfrage Transparenz System.
Und das mache ich indem ich da meine Telefonnummer eingeben und dann kriege ich einen Bestätigungscode 66 Ziffern numerisch,
bin ich noch mal eingebe um zu bestätigen dass ich diese Nummer unter der konnten unter meiner Kontrolle habe und damit meine Anmeldung zu bestätigen und dann bin ich für dieses System angemeldet und werde,
per SMS darüber informiert oder was mache ich das nicht ob das nur per SMS ich werde auf jeden Fall darüber informiert.
Wenn ich zu die Person einer Funktion Abfrage geworden bin für 90 Tage.
Und wenn die 90 Tage vorbei sind muss ich mich wieder neu anmelden.
Mit anderen Worten.
Das Recht auf vergessen.
Ich habe jetzt einen neuen neuen recurring task dass ich mich alle 90 Tage neu da melden muss,
die Argumentation dafür ist natürlich ja man weiß ja nicht wann du vielleicht eine Telefonnummer aufgibst und dir eine neue holst,
und dann die alte Rufnummer noch mal jemanden neuen vergeben wird ein sehr sehr sehr selten vorkommender Fall.
Aber Komfort.
Kommt vor.
Ich halte das tatsächlich bei aller Freude darüber dass es dieses System gibt und der politischen Wichtigkeit für.
Katastrophal dass das so ist denn nur sehr sehr wenige Menschen werden sich dauerhaft bei diesem System angemeldet lassen.
Du wirst irgendwann mal vergessen dein Abo zu verlängern,
du hast irgendwas gleich keine Lust mehr von dem System genervt zu werden oder du lässt meine Woche aus bist du sagst ach ja Mist To-Do-Liste Funkzellenabfrage transparent System Abo verlängern.
Und das ist das ist leider leider sehr schwierig muss ich echt sagen das heißt ja na ich muss mich viermal im Jahr.
Dann neu anmelden und ich beabsichtige noch her zu ungefähr.
Sagen wir mal wie lange ich noch leben oder wie lange wahrscheinlich leid lebe ich noch ungefähr mindestens 20 bis 40 Jahre.
Das heißt ich muss jetzt in die zwischen 80 und 160 Mal in meinem Leben.
Da noch mal melden solange wenn dieser Dienst überhaupt noch so lange in Betrieb ist und meine Befürchtung ist dass es irgendwann früher oder später nicht mehr mache.
Und die andere Befürchtung ist dass dieses System irgendwann wegen mangelnder Nachfrage abgestellt.
Weil die immer sein da gibt's nur noch 56 aluhüte die die scheinen da sie irgendwie Reminder in ihrem Kalender zu haben und so so niedrigschwellig die Anmeldung auch ist muss ich wirklich sagen dass es,
minimalinvasiv ne geht wirklich sehr sehr schnell.
Aber das der Teil ist gut das mit dem löschen finde ich tatsächlich.
Das Davids juristische Gründe für geben ja der nach 6 Wochen wird sie gelöscht damit hast du ne datenschutzrechtlich kannst du sicher sein dass
nach 6 Wochen dann niemand mehr sagen kann dass du überhaupt jemals Interesse daran hattest ja das mussten sind alles Faktoren wie die bedacht werden müssen,
kann ich auch alles verstehen,
aber am Ende heißt dass dieses System wird sein politisches Ziel nicht erreichen nämlich in der Breite der Gesellschaft für eine Transparenz sorgen und das wird das hat zufolge.
Dass viele Menschen diesen diesen Dienst nicht,
in Anspruch nehmen können weil sie vergessen den zu verlängern auch wenn Sie Interesse daran haben und es bedeutet andererseits das dann nachher das politische so ausgelegt wird hier seht ja viel Geld für den ganzen Mist ausgegeben nutze keine Sau,
können wir auch sein lassen.
Na ja man kann ja jetzt Wischmann. Machen und ein initiales Interesse schon mal anmelden den man es vielleicht zumindest jetzt nachhören dieser Sendung oder vielleicht auch noch während.
Des Hörens dieser Sendung einfach mal mitspielen,
Oma guckt was so passiert und dann kann man mal noch mal genauer nachforschen ob das jetzt knallharte rechtliche Rahmenbedingungen sind oder nur ein politisch ausgehandelter Kompromiss und ist der unter Umständen auch noch mal überdenken.
Kannst aber jetzt schon davon ausgehen dass wir eine Balkanisierung der Funkzellenabfrage transparent Systeme haben werden denn.
Nur weil wir jetzt inberlinwohnen heißt das ja nicht dass Leute die nicht inberlinwohnen sich nicht dort anmelden können.
Und gleichzeitig heißt das wenn ich nach,
in ein anderes Bundesland fahre oder so dass ich da nicht mehr den Genuss in den Genuss dieses Funkzellenabfrage transparent Systems kommen als wir haben dann noch einen weiten Weg vor uns.
Ist eine politische Debatte ich meine am Ende brauchen wir das Bundes Notifikation System was einfach generell geben mitteilst so.
Genau eine im Prinzip brauchen wir da wäre es natürlich schön dass auf der Provider Ebene zu haben.
Das ist einfach mit der Verrechnung steht.
Ich auf der Rechnung die Wellis der die Rechnung die hat weil du dir da irgendwie in dein komisches System ein musst aber die.
Passt schon.
Ein ein sinnvolles System wäre natürlich auf ner Bundesebene zentral,
und wäre dann auch von mir aus an den Andi Fett an den Vertrag gekoppelt weil wenn dann irgendwann mal dieser sehr seltene Fall eintritt dass die rufnummer an jemand anderes übergeben wird oder so dann können es von mir aus da Regeln ja.
Unfall man kann ja auch dann im neuen mit den auf dem neuen Teilnehmer gleich mitteilen dass es so ist weil meine wo ist das Problem man kriegt da halt eine nachricht.
IPhone ohne Simlock mit fz82 aber das wäre das wären also die nächsten Schritte ein wichtiger erster ist getan.
Leider mit dieser Einschränkung die ich deswegen so tragisch finde weil ich fürchte dass sie einer breiten Nutzung dieses Systemes.
Im Wege steht.
Jetzt erstmal überlasten dass es Themen dann können wir nächste mal berichten ob es sozusagen den Ansturm von Logbuch Netzpolitik überlebt hat.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Na mal gucken wir mal ob die dran gedacht haben noch eine Warteschleife zu aktivieren.
Aber da sieht man wie Max Weber so schön sagte Politik ist das Bohren dicker Bretter mit dünnen Bohrern und haben wir jetzt in Bora.
Wir müssen weiter Bonn.
Wassergeburt hat auch Freifunk.
Die Initiative für die definiert man das an ich am schönsten Bereitstellung öffentlicher Infrastruktur primär über WLAN also Internet,
Zugang und die Temp schon seit längerem dafür als gemeinnützig anerkannt zu werden.
Und.
Ist das jetzt schon gewesen was haben wir heute Mittwoch heute berät der Wirtschaftsausschuss des Landtags Schleswig-Holstein oder ist die Nachricht vom von der letzten Woche bezieht sich das auf heute.
Ja es ist Mittwoch der 14.11.
Was ja nicht mit Wasser.
Also der ist heute wird das behandelt.
Ob der das sozusagen stattfinden soll oder nicht der CCC und natürlich auch der Förderverein freie Netze sprechen sich für die Anerkennung der Gemeinnützigkeit von Freifunk Initiativen aus und wir sind gespannt,
das Ausgehen.
Die
der sieht ja eigentlich ganz gut aus weil das zwei Anträge gibt der Jamaika-Koalition und der SPD die das Ziel haben diesen Gesetzesantrag in den Bundesrat einzubringen und das,
glaube ich ist doch eine ganz gute Situation das sieht doch gut aus.
Jamaika-Koalition was mal nicht ob das dann noch auf den letzten Metern,
Schlingern gerät nein also sieht danach aus dass diese Mehrheit aus Zustandekommen wird wir können es bloß nicht abschließend sagen ob sie sich nicht alle noch mal die Haare darüber bekommen haben ja dann,
wäre es natürlich auch schön zu sehen wenn das Ganze auf Bundesebene auch seine entsprechende Wirkung erzielen würde.
Und dann kann man nämlich ein Freifunker rein gemeinnützig spenden.
Also spenden kann man jetzt auch schon aber dann kann man die Spenden halt auch absetzen und das natürlich immer gut und hilft.
Digitales - Ehrenamt. Jetzt die Webseite wohl sie,
über diese Idee der Gemeinnützigkeit hinaus eben auch diese diesen Anspruch des Ehrenamtes erheben den ich da sehr charmant finde.
Ich ich administriere ehrenamtlich einen WLAN-Router der Menschen Internet gibt,
natürlich wird der auch genannt wie viele Unterkünfte für geflüchtete von Freifunk mit Infrastruktur versehen wurden weil dort keine brauchbare Infrastruktur war zu dem Zeitpunkt als sie dort ankam,
insofern ist das denke ich schon relativ klar erstens eine ehrenamtliche Tätigkeit und zweitens auch eine Gemeinde.
Na also auf der Webseite könnt ihr wenn ihr möchtet auch noch eure Unterstützung ausdrücken und wir verlinken auch noch ein Podcast Beitrag vom Radio Freifunk,
wo über diese Vorgänge wird diese Initiative diskutiert wird haben wir nicht gehört deswegen, nichts zu sagen aber.
Dann habe ich gerade ja über die OpSec fails gesprochen von einem gewissen deeplab Webseitenbetreiber.
Ist aber auch schön zu wissen dass es sie noch gibt die guten alten Hacker die keine Fehler machen und das ist offenbar Phineas Fisher,
sineus Fischer war der das Pseudonym eines Individuums oder einer Code eines Kollektivs wie auch immer zumindest das Beschuldigte oder dass dich selbst,
Bekennende Pseudonym dass sowohl finfisher als auch hacking Team gehackt hat.
Und,
das war eine sehr interessante wann ihr zwei sehr interessante Fälle im Fall von hacking Team wurde da ein 400GB torrent file,
veröffentlicht indem einfach mal alles war kommt also die Firmen E-Mails Dokumente Kontakte irgendwelche wet sheets wieder hatten und der Quellcode von deren Schatz auf Ferse einmal das gesamte Unternehmen.
Plattgemacht davor ebenfalls erfolgreich aber nicht ganz so ergiebig der Hack von Gamma finfisher der auch mit sehr.
Brauchbaren Informationen aufwartet Evo aber am Ende viele noch sehr interessante Dateien dann PGP verschlüsselt waren so und jetzt haben im Dezember letzten Jahres die,
Staatsanwältinnen und Staatsanwälte darum gebeten dass diese dass dir das Ermittlungsverfahren eingestellt wird weil sie,
alle Spuren verfolgt hätten und nicht herausfinden konnten wer Phineas Fisher ist welche Identität sich dahinter verbirgt.
Und im Juli hat dann eine italienische Richterin oder Richter entschieden dass diese,
Untersuchung nun eingestellt wird weil es keine weiteren Spuren gibt die es zu verfolgen gäbe.
Zeit dass ich meinen Identität Provider gewendet ne.
Hätte ja und die Ermittler sagen dann noch das war eine Organisation die wissenschaftlich und manisch,
die Techniken zur Anonymisierung genutzt hat ja und genau so wird man eben auch nicht erwischt ne also man macht,
eben mein Heft nicht vom heimgerät man bedient sich der notwendigen Sicherheitsmechanismen.
Und so scheint es jetzt eben zu sein das ist Freiheit für Phineas Fisher gibt und das ist doch eine schöne,
Nachricht denn das war ja eindeutig ein Robin Hood der IT Sicherheit der hier unternehmen die nichts anderes im Schilde geführt haben als die IT Sicherheit anderer zu schwächen.
Fertig gemacht hat und,
der Heckers gonna Hack und Heckers gonna be hacked könnte man sagen und da habe ich ja so ganz ganz geringes Mitleid nur mit hacking Team ganz ganz wenig.
Insofern gibt Phineas Fisher an der Matte aus und bestellten schönen Gruß.
Wenn ihr mehr Erkenntnisse abbrechen Staatsanwaltschaft.
Schöne da kriegen wir uns wieder Kommentare die die Linksradikalen Kräfte in der Metaebene freuen sich dass eine Strafverfolgung nicht geglückt ist.
Solltet ihr ja dann gab es noch einen Anruf Horst Paris.
Friedensangebot.
Friedensangebot aus Paris Lippe Cyber heißt es auf französisch.
Cyber Frieden.
Die UN hat damals nicht hinbekommen Frank hat das ja berichtet und jetzt hat am,
12.11 Frankreich den Perez call for trust and security in cyberspace,
formuliert das ist so ein 23 seitiges Dokument mit relativ großer Schrift in der ein Bekenntnis zur Anwendbarkeit von Menschenrechten im Cyberspace gegeben wird indem,
Gesagte das bösartige Cyber Aktivitäten zu Zeiten des Friedens geächtet werden.
Und das eben der Angriff auf kritische Infrastrukturen geächtet wird ziemlich in die Richtung wie Frank das auch geäußert hat hier findet sich natürlich der Teufel auch im Detail weil sie.
Natürlich auch eine Forderung der Strafverfolgung,
fordern die unter Umständen eben auch durch das Schwächen von System wieder gefordert werden könnte,
viel interessanter finde ich China und Russland haben sofort gesagt zu nee,
und die USA irgendwie auch nicht so wirklich haben aber gesagt na wir können wir drüber reden und Unternehmen die Microsoft Google und Facebook haben gesagt ja klar finden wir spannend,
und das ist sehr
interessant zu sehen wie Frank ja auch in der vorletzten Sendung berichtete wie im Leute agieren wenn solche schönen Hey lass uns doch mal ein paar Menschenrechte deklarieren und sagen dass wir einander nicht die ganze Zeit auf die Mütze hauen.
Hier Frieden sie wäre es ja nee also kann man das jetzt.
So so also reden wir das ist ja was das ist ja geil.
Kommt jetzt aber ein bisschen kommt also also mir ist nicht drauf vorbereitet.
Aber es gibt sie noch die guten alten Friedensangebote.
Auch nicht so richtig vorbereitet seid ihr liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer darauf dass diese Sendung jetzt zu Ende geht.
Nur Waldmeister die solange dass sie sich schon darauf eingerichtet haben dass sie gar nicht mehr aufhört dielochis jetzt Arten.
Das schifferhaus ist die unendliche Senderliste hast die läuft immer.
Mein iPhone ist kaputt Design die Sendung hört nicht auf.
Die Lüfter wird mir sowieso thematisch permanent.
Ich sag das nicht das ist auch vielleicht der der Charakter der unsere Sendung so ein bisschen auf ach ja ja ich mal wieder ein bisschen.
Mal gucken wie derselbe Inhalt diesmal formuliert wurde.
Hören wir uns mal wieder ein paar runs zur Überwachung an oder so.
Ja ja mit uns in den Weltuntergang schöner könnt ihr nicht begleitet werden.
Ja was haben wir für titelvorschläge ok Telefon Schläge sind auch ok.
Wir müssen uns auf jeden Fall danach wieder ein zwei Minuten beraten welcher ist denn sein.
Ich würde noch abschließend das habe ich bei den ganzen Thema Kongress nicht am Anfang gar nicht mehr gesagt.
Er weiß auch gerade die Zeit wo die zusagen und Absagen für die Kongress Torx versendet wurden wie ich ja kurz am Rande erwähnte.
Und das ist immer eine Zeit wo unglaublich viele Menschen eine Ablehnung erhalten nämlich in dem Fall wir hatten.
Und das kurz vor Weihnachten.
Das kurz vor Weihnachten wir hatten 600 Einreichungen können ungefähr 150 annehmen das heißt 450 Ablehnungen,
haben am Montag unsere E-Mail Server verlassen.
Die Prozent davon würdest du sagen von diesen 600 waren so dass man nicht lange drüber nachdenken musste die ab zu leben.
Kann ich nicht sagen weil ich nicht alle 600 gesehen habe.
Alucard Yamato hochrech.
Ich habe die 196 Einreichung im Bereich politics ethics and society gesehen.
Was ein Drittel eingeht auf dem Bereich.
Ein Drittel geht auf dem Bereich das andere geht auf Security Security hatte sogar über 200 dann hast du die verbleibenden 200 teilen sich auf über silence art and culture.
Und Resilienz.
Das war viel Arbeit wir nehmen in.
Politics Asics & Society glaub ich.
Sich jetzt mal kurz hier in der spreadsheet schauen wir nehmen relativ nehmen auch viele an ungefähr ein Fünftel dadurch dass dann viele eben gekürzt werden oder Kurzwaren kurz eingereicht waren.
Darf ich dafür so40 ungefähr annehmen grob über den Daumen und.
Ja die anderen 150 die wir allein ablehnen mussten.
Da würde ich sagen ist es bei dem geringeren Teil so dass du sofort ablehnen kannst das sind dann welche die wo die Beschreibung des Torx eindeutig nicht zu Bewertung ausreicht.
Hörzu Berücksichtigung ausreicht also wie sowas wie wird nachgereicht oder lalala das da kannst du dann mal schnell,
agieren aber natürlich musste alle Beschreibung lesen und dann die Frage stellen ok ist dieser torque.
Irrelevant das ist ja in der Regel thematisch sind die relevant wenn ein wenn ein Mensch so
sich dem Thema so gut genährt hat das dass die Person in der Lage ist eine Beschreibung dafür zu liefern und Tork Konzept zu haben in dem drin steht ich beabsichtige folgendes zu sagen dann ist das erstmal ein relevantes Thema,
grundsätzlich jetzt kommt die Frage ist das im Vergleich relevant.
Im Sinne von der Zusammenstellung der Themen in diesem Kongress wo eben die Beschränkung ist wir haben nur so und so viele Slots.
Und sind gezwungen 450 abfüllen.
Da kommst du dann z.b. eine. I feststellst ok es gibt viele Meere Einreichung zu einem Thema agierst du jetzt z.b. indem du sagst okay wir nehmen die davon irgendwie beste,
ja oder vielversprechendste oder wirfst du die zusammen versuchst die Waffe sich in der in in der Zusage in irgendeiner Form zusammenzubringen,
da hast du dann natürlich den Konkurrenzdruck was nämlich genau nicht heißt deine Einreichung war nicht relevant wenn sie abgelehnt wurde sondern.
Deine Einreichung konnte sich unter den constraint das drei bis vier Fünftel abgelehnt werden müssen,
nicht im Vergleich gegen die starke Konkurrenz durchsetzen deswegen ist auch meine Formulierung spezifisch,
diese Einreichung hat es nicht in das Finale Programm geschafft das heißt nicht wir lehnen deine Einreichung abfinden dass,
dein Thema nicht relevant ist und dein Leben einem Inhalt gestiftet wurde welcher unsere Aufmerksamkeit nicht würdig ist,
na was leider Gottes immer wieder Menschen denken,
wenn sie sich in der unschönen Situation wiederfinden dass ihre Einreichung nicht zu den 150 ausgewählten aus 600 gehört ich kann da nur daran appellieren.
Das nicht persönlich zu nehmen auch wenn ich weiß dass das sehr schwer fällt und dass das.
Nicht einfach ist will auch nur dazu sagen bei weitem nicht so tim hatte du hast ja gerade gesagt.
Bei wie vielen kannst du sofort sagen dass okay das hat keine Chance das ist eine geringe Anzahl und alle anderen.
Sind prinzipiell Kandidaten für eine Präsentation und es ist nicht so.
Dass sie am Ende dasitzen mit unserer Auswahl von 40 aus 200 ungefähr.
Und sagen ach ja das sind jetzt auch genau die und da unter den verläuft eine Linie,
und da sind die geistig diese ganzen Tag sie alle irrelevant und abzulehnen sind ganz im Gegenteil wir Schaufeln mehrere Tage,
hin und her bewerten überlegen,
wegen gegeneinander ab und versuchen einen Gesamtprogramm herzustellen und in diesem Gesamtprogramm kommt es dann eben.
Sehr häufig sogar vor dass Einreichung die wir prinzipiell auf der Liste haben von diese einreichen wollen wir haben.
In der Abwägung mit vielen anderen Themen und Einreichungen in diesem Vergleich nicht am Ende ausgewählt werden können.
Das ist die Situation.
Der Prozess ist ja nicht anonym also wenn ihr die Vorträge auswählt wisst ihr auch wer diese Einrichtung gemacht.
Ja das ist so ich bin auch ein starker Verfechter davon dass das so ist.
Aus dem Grunde dass das in der Regel den den Personen,
also ich sehe das selten dass,
die Person das jetzt aufgrund der Person das irgendwie zum Nachteil gereicht ja also die Einreichung ist das was zählt bewertet wird die Einreichung und wenn du jetzt dazu noch schreibst okay ich bin übrigens.
Was heißt ich an einer Universität zu diesem Thema beschäftigt und hier sind meine Veröffentlichung oder so ne dann ist das ein Bonus.
Wenn du das nicht dazu schreibst ist aber kein keine Punktabzug bei die Einreichung wird ja bewährt.
Sind aber teilweise natürlich zu sehen von welcher Person diese Einreichung kommt das hilft z.b. auch dabei im Zweifel was du sehr häufig hast zwei Einreichung sagen, ähnlicher Qualität.
Und ähnlichen ähnlicher Thematik dann zusehen ok die Person hier die hatten.
Background in dem Bereich oder die Person kommt aus nah unterrepräsentiert in Gruppe.
Dass du dann am Ende vielleicht sowas das Zünglein an der Waage sein lassen kannst wenn Du feststellst dass ansonsten die Einreichungen.
Gleicher Qualität sind wenn wir sagen würden wir machen den review process blind was wir im Prinzip machen,
also wir wir gucken ja nicht auf die Person sondern unser unser Interface ist Einreichung und Inhalt das schauen wir uns an und unten steht dass es die Person und da muss man dass es in der Regel Synonym,
was willst du dich kennen ja und dann,
musst du erst da drauf klicken um dir weitere Informationen zu der Person zu holen das Masse in der Regel z.b. bei sensiblen Thematiken ja also wenn es um.
Tim geht die sagen wir mal wo du wirklich sicherstellen musst dass die Person da auch eine Expertise zu hat.
Dann interessiert dich hat die Person Erfahrungen in diesem Bereich was qualifiziert die Person dazu.
Dieses Thema zu behandeln und dann siehst du da was.
Und dann kannst du das zum Vorteil nutzen ist das bestärkt dich er also in der Regel guckst du erst auf die Person wenn du eh schon die Entscheidung getroffen hast dass dieses Thema relevant ist und die Einreichung gut.
Also manchmal auf jeden Fall nicht auf dem user interface wo drauf steht zur hier jetzt Einreichung von Frau oder so was geht erstmal wirklich über das Inhaltliche Oma versucht im gesamten Ausgleich Prozess.
Soweit dann auch eine Gleichverteilung zu erziehen.
Ich kann dir also wir haben keine festen Regeln zur in irgendeiner Form gearteten Bevorteilung von Personengruppen.
Und
wir haben in Paul sag ich habe dieses Jahr mir noch nicht angeschaut aber wir haben bisher immer wenn wir nach der Qualität der Einreichungen,
und zwar nur danach ausgewählt haben am Ende in der Auswahl einen höheren Anteil beispielsweise Frauen gehabt als in den Einreichungen.
Also dass wir wir kriegen nicht 50% Frauen Einreichung ist einfach nicht so einreichungs Anteil Frauen ist irgendwo.
Aber Frauen reichen besser ein.
Bei 10% so vielleicht oder also weiß ich eben nicht habe diese Zahlen dieses Jahr noch nicht errechnet der Frauenanteil ist sehr gering also.
Signifikant geringer aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Frau angenommen zu werden ist größer.
Und zwar unabhängig da unabhängig davon dass das berücksichtigt wird dass die Einrichtung von einer Frau ist auf anhand der Qualität und das bedeutet genau wie du sagst von Frau die durchschnittliche Einreichung einer Frau ist besser als sie durchschnittlich Einreichung eines Mannes und das wiederum liegt glaube ich daran
dass die Frauen im Zweifelsfall gar nicht erst einreichen.
Das ist etwas was wir was ich was nicht gut ist na das müssen wir ändern Ich will genauso viele schlechte Einreichung von Frauen die von Männern haben ja aber das wird.
Im aktuellen in der aktuellen Situation dazu das ohne Einzug.
Von den eben der Anteil von Frauen in der Auswahl größer ist als der Anteil von Frauen in den in dem einreichen.
Ja nicht dass das gut ist ich sage nur dass das der vermutete zugrundeliegende Effekt ist
und das hat das hat wahrscheinlich mit den Faktoren zu tun denen Frauen in diesem Themenbereich größtenteils eben unterliegen dass sie,
in ihrem Umfeld und ihren Kontexten immer symbolisiert bekommen muss ich noch mal extra anstrengen damit du ernst und wahrgenommen wirst dass es nicht positiv,
aber das ergibt den Effekt davon merken.
Zwar einerseits dadurch dass es weniger sind aber andererseits dass wenn der Einreichung kommt sie dann auch tatsächlich mehr Engagement betrieben.
Genau wie vom also ich vermute dass sie erstens mehr sich mehr Mühe geben damit.
Der eine sagt und der Andere fact ist dass es wahrscheinlich einen abschreckenden Effekt gibt den wir versuchen wir versuchen entgegenzuwirken das.
Frauen gar nicht erst einreichen es sei denn die sind sich so dermaßen sicher dass sie eine sehr gute Einrichtung machen können dass sie,
das sieht dann überhaupt schon also erstens die Reichen weniger ein und wenn dann in sehr viel bessere Qualität.
Im Durchschnitt das bitte bitte bitte immer beachten wenn ich so etwas sage dann ist das eine eine Aussage von wenn man die durchschnittliche Qualität betrachtet wenn man einmal nach diesem
nach diesem Kriterium die die Grundgesamtheit der Einreichung trennt und das gilt nur im Bereich politics society und SX.
Und bisher ist es nicht.
Habe ich diese statistische Auswertung auch noch nicht gemacht teilweise also wir haben z.b. auch das Geschlecht dass das Feld Geschlecht nicht.
Keine Ahnung sind auch Einreichung dabei die da ist dann keine Ahnung also kann es jetzt nicht sagen weil die das ja auch vertraulich ist wer da eingereicht hat aber da sind nicht selten,
Pseudonyme die es nicht möglich machen aus dem Namen einen direkten Schluss auf das Schlechte einrechnen Person zu ziehen.
Was kann das sein bestenfalls Essen Nachhinein.
Ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung also gibt's ausgewählt wird eine Einreichung und später spielen natürlich dann Fragen eine Rolle wie,
okay Thema ist wichtig Einreichung ist gut ist dass die Person,
von den anderen hier die dieses Thema behandeln kann ist das die ist dass das Thema was ich im Vergleich mit den anderen Themen durchsetzt und,
da halte ich es dann auch leider sitze jetzt hier nicht gefallen halte ich es leider für richtig dass das Konten Team hier.
Der Aufgabe verpflichtet ist das beste Programme die beste Auswahl zu treffen und es spricht eben für.
Die Einreichungen von Frauen dass diese,
auch ohne eine Förderung spezifischer Natur immer einen größeren Anteil bekommen und eine größere Wahrscheinlichkeit haben angenommen zu werden.
Aber es ist leider,
also sperre ich mich dagegen zu sagen mann oder also eigentlich das glaube das gesamte konnte ein Team ist sich darüber einig dass wir nicht eine Quote von.
Frauen oder sonstigen vorher definieren und die dann ungeachtet der Qualität füllen.
Das wäre eben einen nicht optimales Ergebnis für die Veranstaltung eine Quote haben wir z.b. dieses Jahr vorgegeben für die Talk Sie sich an einen an Einsteigerin und Einsteiger richten wenn mal gesagt ok der Freund es gibt diesen Track foundations.
Wo gesagt wird okay du hast hier werden.
Vorträge gewählt die wirklichen Basen also im weitesten Sinne Basiswissen eines Themenbereich ist
VBL wie funktioniert das Internet was sind die großen nett politischen Themengebiete in diesem Bereich sowas ja oder,
dann wär auch eine Reihe antox angenommen oder warum gibt es Datenschutz.
Wie ist diese Quote also das.
Lieber 15%.
15 % müssen.
Das heißt jetzt auf 150 Slots oder so die da vergeben werden so 22 voneschen.
Das finde ich gut das ist sehr gut weil das auch dem.
Geänderten Publikums Zuschnitt des Kongresses gerecht wird also
nicht so der Zuschnitt sondern einfach der Fakt dass wir immer noch in so einer Wachstumsphase sind von der selber noch nicht ganz absehen können wann sie in so einem Sättigungsphase vielleicht wieder mal übergehen wird,
dass man das
diese hohepriesterliche alles aus legt und sagt nur der neueste heißeste und advantage Scheiß ist gut genug
aber am Ende stellt man fest, wie keiner mehr mit Weiber und wie viel komplett vergessen Nachmalen Teppich auszulegen für Leute die sich den Themenfeldern vielleicht komplett neu widmen und überhaupt erstmal ein Einstieg brauchen und,
sauf wichtig ist dass dass der das der Event daneben auch zu den Leuten spricht und sagt so ja hier Du bist hier schon richtig das mag jetzt teilweise auch alles hat der tubag sein aber wird schon.
Finde ich Installer finde ich ganz viel Sinne auch ein ganz hohes Anliegen das was diese Veranstaltung ein,
ist das der alle Menschen sind die Interesse haben zu lernen und nicht dass da Menschen sind die schon irgendwie ganz viel wissen.
Ja immer das was was.
Immer gesagt du kommst sogar dass das Böse totalen Experten und da muss man doch ganz viele können damit man da akzeptiert wird und so.
Das ist in bestimmten Bereichen der Szene ist das so und in bestimmten Brian ist hin hat das auch ein Grund so zu sein,
na also es wollen sich eben auch ExpertInnen mit Experten unterhalten die das was ich an der.
Spitze.
Der blutigen Kante.
An der blutigen Kante der Krypto Forschung stehen und für die muss da ein Raum sein ja und dann gibt's in die können einen Tag halten
schön Experten Publikum und dann Freunde sich alle und dann geht's dem anderen die halten Publikum um Menschen den Weg zu ebnen auch einmal zu diesen Experten zugehören und,
Stimmkreise und so weiter gibt können jetzt nicht von bleeding-edge Crypto experten erwarten dass die sagen alle gleich wer möchte wer möchte noch mal ein Vorschlag machen
na das ist wieder das nächste Mal verschlüsseln so das ist klar dass die dann auch eben mit ihr in in N Expert Hinrunden sitzen.
Aber es heißt eben nicht dass Menschen die keine expertisa haben da nicht hin dürfen und noch dazu kommt, die Themen sind so breit ne,
der hat sowieso kein Mensch expertise in allen Bereichen,
nag2 irgendwie als Security interessierte Person hin guckst du deine Security Torx ein anguckst dir mal diese die Politik talks an und dann gibt es ja noch mal irgendwie ein lustigen
Teil aus dem Kunst und Kulturbereich um dein Horizont da ein bisschen zu erweitern und so ist das,
H&M gleichzeitig aber auch das auch so ein Thema was mich immer wieder.
Das auch so ambivalent ist.
Das Interesse an Wissensaustausch.
Und lernen und diese Offenheit das wird vorausgesetzt und wer wer das nicht hat.
Lasse die Leute auf der Veranstaltung falschen wäre da sagt nur ich komme aber nur hierhin um meine Sicht der Dinge zu replizieren und möglichst vielen zu erklären.
So wie ich.
Und nicht um auch mal einfach mich hinzusetzen die Klappe zu halten und zuzuhören was sie so riesige Veranstaltung hier alles an Wissen zu bieten hat was ich noch nicht,
habe so wie ich wenn ich in ihrem zum Park sitze und dann irgendwie,
Crypto Professor da irgendwie die elliptische Kurve hast du nicht gesehen diskutieren ist das so.
Ja meinetwegen aber komm nicht so spät nach Hause.
Wo war noch mal oben wo unten was bedeutet was bedeutet XR.
Diese Mischung diese Mischung macht's und sor kann es jeder Mensch der diese Offenheit und dieses Wissen gegen diese Offenheit gegenüber anderen mitbringt.
Und da urteilsfrei auch auf das dass ich die Tracks guckt die jetzt nicht.
Dein Lebensinhalt sind ja das sind die Person die da die da.
Und das ist die Magie dieser Veranstaltung.
Ich hoffe dass alle die sich jetzt auch angesprochen gefühlt haben auch in der Lage waren ein Ticket zu sichern für diesen Kongress will wissen dass die Nachfrage immer noch größer ist als das was wir so organisatorisch
anbieten können und als Wachstum auch verkraften können.
Bin sehr gespannt wie sich die das zweite Mal manifestiert ich glaube dass wir,
schon noch mal einen dritten Anlauf brauchen werden um dieses Monster Leipzig also nicht die Stadt drin diese Veranstaltungsort die Messe für uns zu erwirtschaften aber,
na die auch relativ sicher dass oder wieder ein paar neue Antworten finden auf Probleme die wir letzte Mal festgestellt haben und so geht das weiter noch nicht ganz so nah dran sind.
Kirschen durchgespielt zu haben aber das schaffen wir auch noch.
Pannewitz bestimmt auch dieses Jahr wieder schöne schöne Dinge geben ich wünsche mir einfach ehrlich gesagt dass das also mein Hauptziel oder mein Haupt Wunsch dieses Jahr ist das da wieder mehr.
Von dem Hamburger Hamburg.
Kuschel Kongress.
Hamburger Community Gefühl und der Hamburger Freundlichkeit,
Wer war im in Hamburg war man war das näher.
Mehr Austausch gefühlt einfach vom Weib her und den wünsche ich mir in Leipzig auch wieder unter den Leuten und tatsächlich auch merke ich.
In verschiedenen Themenbereichen.
Wirklichen Erfahrung der Auseinandersetzungen über Themen über die im Prinzip einigkeit herrscht und das sieht man.
Fütter schon jetzt dass da wieder Leute meinen sie müssten.
Irgendwelche Kämpfe gegeneinander führen.
Die Veranstaltungen im weitesten Sinne zu einem nicht positiven Erlebnis für alle werden zu lassen und ich hoffe dass,
dass diese Kräfte in der Minderheit bleiben.
Ja dass die Kräfte vielleicht auch selber mal begreifen dass sie hier vielleicht auch sich selber von 3 Ereignissen leiten lassen werden hier schön die Diskussion mit frank zum Cyberwar und deren ein primäres Ziel ist die Zerrüttung,
der Debatte in der Gesellschaft und soweit wenn wir es nicht kommen lassen.
Das wird das wird ein schöner Kongress und wir werden eine schöne Zeit.
Ein schönes Sendungsende und ich danke an dieser Stelle noch kurz den Christian vielen vielen Dank.
Das warst du heute bis bald.